want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one problem that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
that you've got michael jordan level
talent at something so today let's get
some ultimate motivation from one of the
best
dan lok
many years ago i had this conversation
with my mentor
and he asked me the question dan what do
you think is the number one quality
of an entrepreneur and i said many many
things i said talents
and i said team and i said good idea i
said many many many things he said no
he said the number one quality of a
successful entrepreneur is this
and that is the ability to endure pain
for a long period of time
then talk about the ferrari then talk
about the big house
paying for a long period of time is that
you
what are you willing to give up what
price are you willing to pay to
accomplish success to build your
business
i could tell you any successful
entrepreneurs that i know
almost all of them experience
pain for a long period of time before
they accomplish
even just a little bit of success i
thought
that happiness is a destination if i i
get to some place i
make certain amount of money if i own
certain amount of things
then i would be happy then i realized as
i
am now older and a little bit more
mature and a little bit wiser
that it's not happiness is not something
that you seek
it's something that's already within you
but
a lot of times we are blocking it so you
think about why people are depressed
why feel unhappy usually it's because
when their expectation because you have
a certain expectation of how your life
should look like
how where you should be at this by this
point and your reality
when your expectation and your reality
when they don't match up
you get depressed you feel very very
unhappy
because this is where you are this is
where you think you should be
and the bigger this gap
the more unhappy you are so to be
happier you can do two things
you can either lower your expectation
so then your gap is not as large example
you want to make a billion dollars and
you're making now a thousand dollars a
month
well you will feel very unhappy
very very much unhappy because you think
this is where i should be and this is
where i'm at
well if you low expectation oh you said
100 bucks you're low expectation i'm
gonna make a
a hundred and two dollars right now
you're making a hundred
okay now you're not so bad i'm only sure
two dollars right that's okay
so you can lower expectation which is
what you can do
or you can now change your reality
how you can shorten the gap right that's
what an achiever does
how do you match how do you push and
challenge your reality
to match to your expectation you could
do that
or the other way that i look at it is
this when i start the day
with attitude or gratitude coming from a
place of
giving coming from a place of love
coming from a place of
i have enough right i have enough
because whatever your goal is you're
getting the same thing but just more
right you have one car you want two cars
you want three cars but it's the same
thing
if you're not grateful you don't
appreciate what you have now
you're not gonna appreciate what you'll
get then so i
am grateful with what i have i start
with that
while achieving what i want right i'm
grateful with what i have
while achieving what i want next when i
start from this place i just find that
i'm much happier like today i'm a happy
guy believe me
one of the things that holds people back
that i believe is fear
fear of failure i want you to ask
yourself this question
what would you do differently if you
knew
you couldn't fail would you take more
risk
would you be more aggressive you don't
need to be afraid of failure
i'll give you a perfect example when i
was
making an offer when i was
driving people to take an action and
investing in themselves
when i'm speaking to a group of audience
maybe a hundred people 200 people
500 people on a good day i might have
10 15 20 of the people
in the audience they will take action
and they will invest in themselves
so you would say wow that's a 20 success
rate
yes there is a 20 success rate but the
other way to look at this is
basically i fail even on a good day
80 of the time i would get
a rejection 80 percent of the audience
would say
no in marketing when you are
running traffic when you're doing your
marketing online let's say you get a
three percent conversion meaning
a hundred people this is your website
three percent
will take action they say your
conversion of three percent
97 would say no 97
would not buy and 97 would not take
action well guess what you have a 97
failure rate you see anyone who achieves
any kind of success
experience failure on a consistent basis
whatever you're going through right now
i know may be very very difficult
and it almost feels like the end of the
world in your own little world
right in your own little world i want
you to imagine
that you are now
three years five years maybe even 10
years
from today and now you're looking back
and what's happening
right now and you ask yourself some of
these questions
is this as bad as i thought it is what
can i learn from this
i know it's very difficult you're saying
i not learn nothing from it
there's nothing i'm learning from this
no what are some of the lessons you
could you could take away
what's some of the value you get from
this right it's going to be the most
difficult one
what could you be grateful for that this
happened to you
and you're like oh come on come on dan
there's nothing to be grateful for
this accident happened this emergency
happened
or something tragic that just happened
like there's nothing that i could be
grateful for
i know but if there is something you
could be grateful for what could you be
grateful for
ask yourself those questions suddenly
that would give you perspective
and when you come back to reality where
you are now you're looking at scenario
okay
if it's ten years from now maybe it's
not as bad imagine
even things that happened to in the past
the adversities that you experienced in
the past
think about that it could be two three
five ten years ago
back then that felt like the end of the
world that felt like it's the worst
thing that's
ever happened to you back then now
looking
today looking back back then how do you
feel about those incidents
my bad is this it is not as bad as you
thought
and you learn a lot from it and probably
you find something that you could be
grateful for that
that adversity turns out to be one of
the greatest thing
that's ever happened to you successful
people have great habits
unsuccessful people have lousy habits
like smoking drinking taking drugs
watching too much tv
you see successful people are where they
are today because
of their habits habits determine 95
of a person's behavior everything that
you are today
everything that you will accomplish in
the future is determined by the quality
of the habits
that you form what i found that is the
very best people have the best
habits you see successful people are
simply those
with successful habits successful habits
could be
getting up in the morning meditate
reading
exercising regularly how many of these
habits do you have
i'm just an introvert i'm not good with
people
and i'm just like it's okay i don't i
don't like to talk i'll just be like
that
right you use that as an excuse you use
that to stay in your own bubble
you use that to stay in your own shell
guess what
believe it or not i was a very very shy
person i was an introvert i was the kid
when i was going through high school i
had no friends i didn't want to talk to
people because i couldn't speak the
language
i was so afraid even now sometimes when
i
go to meet a lot of people i still
sometimes have that little bit of
awkwardness
it's normal but i don't let that hold me
back i know if
i want to be more successful if i want
to be rich
i have to get outside of my comfort zone
i have to overcome
my shyness that's how i could do what i
do so don't use that
your personality as an excuse to hold
you back
to be a great leader to inspire other
people here's what i believe in
that you must have something that is
bigger than yourself in order to
inspire people in order to enroll people
into your
vision example if you talk to your
employee you talk to your team member
and you say hey you know what this is
why we're doing this so that i could
make enough money so that i could retire
or so that i could build this business
so that i could be you know living the
10 hour week or 12 hour work week to be
a lifestyle entrepreneur
see that doesn't inspire anybody because
it's all about me me me me me
so to be a great leader to inspire other
people
you got to have a vision that is so big
they're so
compelling that other people want to be
part of that
right it's like imagine you are the
captain of this
ship and you're saying hey this is where
we're going we're going to this
island and it's going to be great and we
are going to
to have all these great things when we
get there
and that's like wow you know people look
at that say yeah i want to be part of
that
but i want to i want to join this
journey i want to
i want to join alongside and and be
alongside
with you and maybe there's some
obstacles there will always be
challenges
there will be waves in the ocean but
that's okay
i want to join you and help you to fight
along and be alongside with you
going through this journey so i believe
very much
that leader needs to think about what is
your mission
don't start a business if you don't
understand the industry
i always ask this question before you
start any business and that is
and i'm asking you right now why you and
why now
if your answer is oh i just want to make
some money you're going to fail
why you and why now what qualifies you
to be in this space right now not what
you saw on facebook
oh that sounds like a good idea this
person this guy is making so much money
doing this i should jump into that too
no why you and why now
in order to make money in any industry
you have to understand the industry if
you don't know the industry
first you have to learn the industry
let's say you want to go
open up a restaurant and i'm not saying
that's a good idea but let's say you
want to open up a restaurant
well isn't it a good idea to just go
work at a restaurant
see what's the day-to-day operation like
what's it like to to work in a
restaurant before you open up a
restaurant so you have to know your
industry things are fine
you know i don't need to be the
ambitious well that's the problem
your income zone is your comfort zone
your comfort zone is your income zone
when you get complacent when you get
comfortable you are not growing
remember when you're not growing you are
dying so do you have this ego
that is holding you back right now and
what are you gonna do about it
when did you realize dur in your
platform
closing career your speaking career like
that's all i'm gonna focus on
impact and serving well there are two
incidents that happen right so first is
when i hit
30 years old
there one day i got in the morning of
tears coming down my cheek
yes and i was crying i don't know why i
was crying i would just
have this depression coming over me
which i
i don't get depressed right it doesn't
happen to me
and i realized i've up to that point the
way i lived my life
that i've grown a company and made a lot
of money but
i wasn't being who i wanted to be
right because i was 20 to 30 years old
like the seafood that you see today
more and more pearl but you could see
from time to time
i have that yeah right right right here
but i was
all that before yeah i was all that
like that right i it's that and more
okay
wasn't treating very very people very
nice okay uh wasn't
just arrogant because i felt i'm so
smart and i'm smart
but i it's it's a wrong attitude right
uh so when i hit 30 years old when that
happens depression and that's when i
realized okay i need to
look for something else so remember like
my both mom and dad they're pearls right
and my big dan my mentor is like extreme
ruby
right you guys know yeah
yeah so i the first so i thought that
was the way you have to be to be
successful
i didn't have any other role model and a
five father figure so
from there i try to be big then
okay like do what he does and all that
and it wasn't
and i i got to a certain point but i
wasn't happy
so that was first turning point right
okay then i realized i went to deep dive
in terms of spiritual work in terms of
even religious work i did a lot of
studying and i found my
kind of new path right so that's number
one second is when my father passed away
right when i'm chasing a deal that was
just chasing the next success
and i thought that would make him proud
well in fact he passed away
i can like that i must miss that chance
that's when i realized that's not what
life is about
because when my father passed away i'm
like okay
it's it's real like the people closest
to you they could
they could leave and then now i started
asking what's my legacy right
what what do i want to be right do i do
i want to
keep going i can make a lot of money
which i'm very good at making money no
problem
right but then i would think about one
thing that also when i went to the bruce
lee
grave in seattle right
you know i was there every five minutes
there's someone going there
every five minutes after all these years
every five minutes from
all kinds of background for all kinds of
country countries people bring flowers
and all that
i'm like that's a legacy right that's a
legacy he's an iconic
martial artist actor that lives through
all this age
right and i'm like i'm not saying like
i'm boosting anything i'm just saying
that wow right so that inspires me
that's when i shift my focus
into here's the number one success
secret that
no one talks about and no one shares
this is something i've learned from my
mentor dan pena the 50 billion dollar
man
self-esteem is the foundation of all
success
now i'm not talking about arrogance i'm
not talking about pride
i'm not even talking about just
confidence i'm talking about
self-esteem now what is self-esteem
self-esteem is something that your
parents
didn't give you think about when you're
growing up when you want to do something
when you want to take some risk
what did your parents what are your
friends what did they tell you
you're not trained for this no one in
our family is an entrepreneur
or you don't have enough education or
you don't know the right people
just be content right be happy with what
you have
or hey son i want you to be successful
but not too
successful i want you to think about
what is holding you back
the goals that you have that you want to
achieve why don't you do what you know
deep down that you are supposed to do
why don't you take that risk
why don't you start that business what's
stopping you
because you lack self-esteem now the
next question you might have
sifu dan how do i build my
self-esteem let me give you a perfect
example
let's say you have a friend of yours and
he tells you all the time hey man let's
let's hang out say okay you know what
let's hang out let's go grab a drink
let's go you know go for a hike every
single time
he says okay let's do something he would
cancel on you
and that happens again and again and
again so let me ask you a question if
that happens all the time how would you
feel about this friend this person would
you trust
him or her not so much the reason
you don't have high self-esteem because
you have a lousy track
record meaning how many times you
promise yourself that you're going to do
something but you don't
how many times you make promises to
yourself and you don't deliver
you don't follow through on those
promises and guess what when you do this
enough
for enough times for enough years you
have low self-esteem because you know
you know yourself well yeah i guess i
want to do that but
i'm not going to follow through i'm not
going to make it happen and that's why
your self-esteem is low
you don't even believe in yourself
little things big things
you make a promise to yourself and you
deliver successful people are incredibly
driven how driven are you now i'm not
talking about you being a nightmare to
work with or bullying other people
i'm talking about you pushing yourself
to get
results it's your personal drives that
turns your ideas into actions
into results it is your personal drive
that keeps you going when things get
tough it is your personal drives
that enables you to bounce back from
disappointment
from setback so how driven
are you or are you lazy do you
procrastinate
do you put things off you see for the
first five years of my career
i didn't take a single day off
i was working 10 12 14 hours
every single day for five years
straight why because i was driven
i was driven to provide for my family i
was
driven to prove other people wrong and
today
i am driven by my mission how driven
are you the fact i like martial art
because it's
it's not a physical sport sure it's a
mental sport
that's right right because a lot of
times well you can play
tennis or you can play golf you can play
all that it's nice
yeah but martial art is a sport where
let's say i'm hitting a heavy bag yeah
right
doesn't matter how good you get you're
competing with yourself
that's right and it's all about limiting
eliminating your own
defect i can throw a punch
well i can throw a punch but can i hit
it with speed right can i hit it with
power that's right
all that i need to learn and practice
and do all that stuff so
i love that part of it and it's a
never-ending challenge
it's never good it's never good enough
you find someone that can do it faster
bigger like
stronger for sure so i love that there's
always someone that's going to be better
than you and i can go
super philosophical right where i can
not have my physical i can just
goes off philosophical with it and i can
do that extreme
i love that crazy deep dive of life and
philosophy
excellent i love that aspect love it you
see you can make money or you can make
excuses
but you cannot do both an excuse
is nothing more than a well planted
lie you see the excuses ego says
well i can't afford it i don't have
money
right or or that's too far or that's
too too difficult or two i don't have
enough experience
it's always i can't i can't i can't or i
don't know
how you see you could have a million
excuses
why you cannot do something you only
need one damn good reason why you must
do it back then when i was going to high
school
in canada and vancouver i had no friends
right because i was very much an
introvert i was very shy
because i couldn't speak a language when
i first arrived
to this country i couldn't speak a word
of english so
i was very afraid to talk to people of
course when you're afraid to talk to
people
no one would listen and i remember i
would try to
communicate very very even simple
language simple words
uh with my classmates and they were like
what
what they say part of me and i would
have to repeat
the same thing three four five times
and because they just won't listen and
eventually they pretty much just lose
their patience they're like i know i
can't understand you man i can't
understand what you're talking about
so they don't want to talk to me because
they feel it's it's very
troublesome for them right so i know
for a fact when you see what i do when
i'm now
communicating with you that i can speak
i can commend an audience
and our fans you know from all over the
world that
communication this is a
learnable skill it is a what it's a
learnable
skill this is something that you could
learn i could
go from someone who's a totally
introvert shy no one would listen to me
to now that people would listen to what
i have to say
the fake ego have you ever met someone
that you don't know them but
the minute you meet with them they just
have this weird kind of vibe that
you don't trust him or her or they feel
very fake
that you feel like oh my god they're
just so fake they're so
superficial that you don't make that
connection that they're not genuine
or have you ever met someone that just
the minute you meet with them you make
the instant connection
and then there's that trust that's that
bond
that you feel this person is sincere the
fake ego
maybe that's you may be that you're very
good
at putting on this mask you're very good
that in one circumstance you can be this
person
in another scenario you become a
different person and then here you
become another person
and before you know it you've done it
for so many years
you don't know who you are anymore you
don't know which one is the real you
which one is the real you you've lost
yourself
be yourself everyone else is taken
be yourself i would rather people hate
me
for who i am than love me for who i am
not
so don't don't use the fake
ego you don't need it to be successful
what i'm do doing right now right this
path
is it going to get me there right if you
are working at a minimum wage job
and you say you want to make six figure
a year you want to make
you know a quarter million dollars a
year well what are the chances of
whatever you're doing right now that
would get you there
right and if not doesn't matter what you
do
it's just that's the wrong path because
this path will never get you there
when you're watching someone's video
when you are
following someone on social media to me
that is
learning but that's not mentorship
mentorship is much more
intimate it's much more
special it's not just watching someone
passively
so to me there are a lot of people that
you could learn from and i learned from
a lot of people
over the years i mean i i read so many
books and attend so many workshops and
and every lunch and dinner and and all
these people that are business people
that i interact with i learn from them i
hear their stories i hear their
struggles i hear about
their best practices however when it
comes to
mentoring when it comes to having a
mentor i've only
had really now up to this point in my
life three mentors
in my life first one his name is alan
allen's my very first mentor he taught
me marketing
and copywriting right if you've watched
my video you know that
um second and it's been my mentor since
i was
20 in my early 20s gave me my
opportunity
right to to to work for him for one year
for next to nothing really is working
for free but i learned a tremendous
amount from him
and he gave me the opportunity he
he gave me the a chance
right he believed in me when no one
believed in me
my second mentor dan pena the 50
billion dollar man right you might have
seen him on
on youtube in fact i'm going to visit
him in
in scotland uh in a couple months and he
was here if
you saw my videos my interview with him
so he's been my mentor for more than a
decade now that's my second mentor
and my third mentor my new mentor mr
dwayne during clock
and doing is a super super successful
man
with with great values and so that's my
third mentor
so really i learned from everybody but
when it comes to
selecting that right mentor i'm very
very selective
i want to pick someone that i could
learn from for
a long time because most people when
they pick someone
they see someone on youtube they see
someone on your social media i want to
live with that person i want to learn
from that
person i live from that person well the
problem with that approach is
think of it like martial art imagine you
are
learning you're taking a lesson a you
want to learn boxing this week
next weekend you learn brazilian jiu
jitsu and then
the week after you learn chinese kung fu
and and then the
next month you learn something else
you'll never get good at it you
never never get good at anything because
you're jumping from one thing to another
see when i was broke i thought i know it
all
i don't need to read books i know what
i'm doing i was starting all these
businesses and guess what none of them
worked
because i thought i knew what i was
talking about guess what
i didn't know okay you don't know
see the know-it-all always thinking they
know everything keep doing the same
thing again and again
and expect a different result that's the
very definition
of insanity when you are
an entrepreneur right when you are
running your own company
it is not something that you do is who
you are when it is who you are
this doesn't turn off there's no such
thing as
oh well you know i don't want to work on
weekends i take the two-week vacation
when you're entrepreneur you're going
all the time
because as i always say that's why i
don't watch sports i don't need to watch
sports to get some chip thrill
entrepreneurship it is the most
competitive
sport in the world because when you
watch any sport game
guess what you're playing for 30 minutes
60 minutes whatever how much
amount of time well with entrepreneur
24 7 someone somewhere is trying to
kick your ass somewhere someone
somewhere
they try to steal your customers they
are trying to grab
market share it is 24 7. so we have to
be thinking about how can we be better
how can we
uh serve our customer better how can we
deliver more value
this is ongoing there's no work life
balance or how to separate the two i
don't mean my life around my business
i build my business around my lifestyle
preference
so right now i'm going somewhere i'm
going i'm gonna do an interview
i'm filming i'm creating content i'm
connecting with you
that's integration when i'm traveling
i'm traveling for business
at the same time i will be travel for
pleasure
take a few days off it's integration
versus i work at work i work i work
oh my god man i can't take this no more
i need to escape from this i need to
avoid this
i need to go somewhere and then from
there i need to totally unplug
so don't bother me for a week oh man
i'll take a vacation i'm sitting the
beach
doing nothing and then come back oh my
god man you're kind of dragging your
feet
now you got to get back to work it
doesn't work that way so i would find
the timing between
how do i recharge my battery now in my
case i like movies
so i don't need to take you know two
weeks off in order to recharge
what i need is maybe jenny and i we go
to watch a movie two hours i'm recharged
a good night's sleep i'm recharged i'm
back in the game i still get
like comments youtube
like racist right i look like psy
i look like kim jong-un
right every day i get that
that's okay that's okay they're not who
i want to impact
right remember if you have a million
people watching your
your content 10 don't like you that's
100 000 people
when i have 10 million people watching
my content that's a million people not
liking me yeah that's a lot of people
a million people like and and because
sifu is so
direct and blunt and provocative right
like it's right
so people hate me really hate me like
it's not like oh i kind of don't like
this i
hate your god like you die like it's
like very
like direct stuff right because it's too
it irks them right yeah but at the same
time i keep watching my stuff for it's
hilarious how it works
i see like i have haters everything like
same hate comment you suck okay then
watch all my video
i upload 9 a.m you can see like negative
comment right there same dude
like thumbs up immediately
don't watch my stuff but they keep
watching my stuff you see what holds a
lot of people back is
fear fear of success fear failure
fear of making a mistake think about it
before you do something
you're saying to yourself well what if
it doesn't work or what if what if i
lose money
and what if what if i make a mistake
then what happens what if i don't know
what to do
what if i can't figure this out what if
what if what if what if what if it does
work
you see always remember fear is an
acronym it stands for
false evidence appearing real
it's nothing more than a made-up story
in your own mind so do you
have the fearful ego holding you back
instead of thinking now we in we're no
longer in a
job economy we're in a skilled economy
that you need to think much more like a
an independent
person with skill set that you offer it
could be to companies
or to different businesses or to the
marketplace instead of
thinking oh a job we provide for you you
need that flexibility
right developing what i call that high
income skill and a number of videos on
youtube you can search on youtube
download high income skills you'll find
that
so don't think oh i'm seeing the job
economy
that job economy that credentials
economy where
a piece of paper a piece of paper is not
going to protect you
when there's an economic downturn a
piece of paper is not going to
prevent you from being laid off a piece
of paper
is not going to prevent that your
industry turn upside down and
and then this massive change that's
happening it's not going to protect
anybody
what no one could take away is your
skill set the value that you know you
could provide
to people to the marketplace to
companies no one can take that away from
you
so focus on skill not just
a job people ask me all the time dan why
do you talk about money
all the time you see there's nothing
wrong or evil about money
money is neutral imagine if you enjoy
talking about basketball
raptors nba canadian team right
if you enjoyed playing basketball or
watching basketball would you be ashamed
to talk about basketball with
your friends your buddies no you
wouldn't then why would you be ashamed
talking about money you see you have a
story in your
mind right now about health about
success
about life and also about money you have
a story in your mind right now and
guess who created those stories it could
be your parents
it could be your relatives it could be
people that you know you love your
brothers and sisters
your cousins it doesn't matter but you
picked up
those stories from somewhere remember
when you were a little kid
the horror story the scary story the
spooky story
and the the boogeyman hiding the closet
someone planted those thoughts in your
mind and someone planted those
thoughts about money in your mind as
well that it's hard to get money
that rich people are bad that you have
to do something bad to
to make money and and it's one thing to
make money
and it's very difficult to keep money
and if you make the money and now you
lose it then you look really really
stupid it is simply not true
the people who are struggling with money
they're afraid to talk about
money and believe me they do talk about
money the difference is they argue
over money do your parents argue
over money do you argue over money with
your loved one
your spouse your boyfriend and
girlfriend
i remember one of the few times in my
life that i saw my mom cried
was because we ran out of money so
remember
money secret number one money moves to
those who are not
afraid to talk about it i'll try to do
something
well i tried see when you use the word
try the minute you use that word
you are setting yourself up for failure
you're giving yourself a way out
when something doesn't work out well you
know i try i try my best
i'll try to call you man right i try do
this with me
i want you if you're sitting down if
you're standing up you're doing
something you're watching me right now
listen to me i want you to try
to walk a step forward
try to walk a step take a step
no no no i didn't say walk a step i said
try
to walk a step towards me go ahead
no i didn't say move a step i said try
try to move no i did not say move a step
i said try
to move a step you see the state of
trying
doesn't exist it is a made-up [ __ ]
story that we created in our own minds
the state of try
it doesn't exist either you do or you
don't
there is no such thing either you're
movable you take a step forward or you
don't take a step forward
there is no try try means
nothing it means nothing happens so
eliminate that word from your vocabulary
one of the things i teach all my
students who are learning closing from
me
very simple i teach them a role player
day keeps property away
right every single day you spend at
least invest at least
one hour role-playing and honing your
skills
it's that simple it's an integration
it's not like well
today i don't feel like i'm gonna
role-play or maybe i'll do it tomorrow
and then you procrastinate
and you don't do it for a week and then
guild kicks in saying oh i know i should
have done that but i didn't do it now if
i do it it's kind of
too late that looks stupid in front of
people you see all these bs
in your mind versus hey you know what
i'm going to do an hour a day
and now they will play period that's it
there's no thinking i don't want you to
think about it i don't want you to
hesitate i don't even want you to do it
just
integrate it into your life every single
day i'm going to do an hour role play
period if you want to improve your
closing skill you see it takes all the
decisions making out
out of your thoughts all these bs in
your in your mind
take that away and just do that you are
walking down the street
and suddenly you hear
and suddenly you see a red ferrari
just drove by what's the first thought
that
comes through your mind comment below no
filter
no edit just comment below what's the
very first thought that comes to your
mind
my guess is chances are he's an [ __ ]
who does she think he is so cocky
so selfish probably a greedy bastard
actually you know what
probably is not his money anyway it's
his daddy's money or if it's a ladies a
woman oh that's a gold digger right
all these negativities guess what that's
you
judging other people my question to you
is how do you know
how do you know it's all made up stories
in your mind
right and you say oh he's not that good
she's not that pretty he's not that
smart
you're judging other people you're
projecting your own
insecurities your own values onto other
people
how do you know that man is not a hard
working man
how do you know he's not a good husband
how do you know he's not a family man
how do you know he's someone who's
worked 20 30 years
to get to where he is at this point how
do you know
you judge you come to your own
conclusions before even talking to the
person you see how your mind works
how are you going to be successful how
are you ever going to become rich if
that's the image that you have for
people who are successful
you see this on social media very often
people talk about
the morning ritual or waking up very
very early in the morning because
all successful people they all wake up
in the morning so
do you actually need to wake up early
early in the morning to be
successful that's one of the problems
with people don't know how to filter
advice now
are there a lot of people who are
successful
who wake up in the morning absolutely
but are there also
a lot of people who are successful who
don't wake up in the morning
absolutely right but is this propaganda
on social media
that people focus so much on that
success has to do with your
habits what you do on a consistent basis
and you have to know
what time in the day that you're the
most productive
for some people it is early in the
morning where there's no distraction
there's people are still sleeping and
you go through the day maybe you go work
out maybe you do meditation
then you plan the day that's fine for
some people
they don't wake up early they wake up
whatever time and then they work
late at night they're more like a night
out i'm more like a nile i find that i'm
the most creative late at night when
it's quiet
when there's no noise right when there's
not a lot going on i find that that's
those quiet times sometimes become my
thinking time
so that's what works for me i think you
need to find what works for you
doesn't matter whose advice you're
getting from it could be
from me it could be from anybody else
but you have to know yourself
enough if it doesn't work for you if you
get up in the morning you're like oh my
god i'm so tired
you're sleepy you're exhausted and for
many many days and dutch
just like it screws up your biological
clock then it doesn't work for you
and that's kind of one thing that i
gravitate towards
bruce lee's martial art as you follow my
work you know my martial artist
that bruce is always about you finding
your own path
that's why he said his martial art style
is not a style it's a set of principles
you define what works for you absorb
what is
useful reject what is useless and add
what is
eventually on your own when you are
successful
you actually experience failure
much faster much much more on a daily
basis
but it doesn't matter because the ones
that said yes
that's what builds your business that's
what helps you to achieve
your goals so from now on i don't want
you to think a word
failure i want you i want you to replace
the word failure
from from your vocabulary from your mind
instead use this word feedback
it is feedback not failure
it's simply feedback from your customers
from your prospects from your clients
from the marketplace
hey maybe this offer is not what we want
or maybe the price point is not
something that
they are comfortable with or maybe the
way that you
articulate you'll share your message you
communicate the value
it doesn't resonate with the with the
prospects of the marketplace
every single action that you take you're
gonna get some not failure you're gonna
get some
feedback then you're going to be able to
pivot you can
make changes to your approach you're
going to learn something from it so next
time
you're going to do it just a little bit
better and knowing this
the more feedback that you get the
faster you get those feedbacks we'll
talk about
fail forward right fail fast forget fail
fast it's
getting feedback fast knowing hey this
is waste of time this doesn't work no
problem
forget it now let me try this and more
feedback
maybe don't like the feedback but that's
okay it doesn't work i know i don't need
to waste more time
and then boom hey the marketplace my
customers they like this
perfect that's good now that's the
feedback that you want
when you're going through the
adversities when you're going through
all
these things normally put some distance
but another thing that you could do is
talk to someone that has already
gone through that one of the things that
i'm very fortunate
because i have a lot of peers
very successful mentors um people around
me
that whatever adversity even today that
i experience
bad that happens right which i still do
that oh
maybe like it would feel i would feel
frustrated i would feel like
maybe i'm not sure what to do but i
would talk to someone
they say talk to a mentor and he would
laugh and say yep i experienced that 30
years ago
35 years ago and here's what you need to
do and they would share with me my
perspective
suddenly i don't feel so bad because
what happens is when you
experience any kind of problem any kind
of adversity you
think you're the only one in the world
that's experiencing this
not true i could tell you from
experience a lot of people have
experienced
the same things you're much luckier at
least you have a youtube channel
that you could come visit and
see and get information and get insights
i didn't have any of that back then mark
cuban reads three hours a day bill gates
reads at least
one hour per day i go to two to three
books
per week for years now i'm still
constantly learning
all the time i'm not just talking about
reading a book it could be listening to
a podcast talking to other
successful people getting coaching from
your mentors
but successful people we're always
learning and growing and we never
stop one time i was asking a very
successful person out for lunch he's
been very successful for so many years
he's in a merger and acquisition
space he's had multiple successful exits
sold multiple companies
at a very young age when we sat down and
we're sitting across
each other and when we had that meal the
first thing that he did is he pulled out
a journal
and taking notes and started asking me
questions
learning i was the one who wanted to
learn from him but it turns out
into a learning session that he's
learning from me
i'll never forget that because you see
the more you know the more you realize
you don't know the less you know the
more you think you know
if you're down right now
if you're not where you want to be right
now
if you're not successful right now
don't worry because the signs of success
are not obvious what often
looks like a failure on the service is
just a stepping stone
towards success so wherever you are
in your journey you need to realize
your adversity is your greatest
advantage your pain
is your greatest tool because
happiness does not change you pain
does comfort does not move you
adversity does
[Music]
realize that your toughest times
will turn you into the toughest
person
what doesn't kill you will make
you stronger don't hide your pain
don't run away from your struggles use
it
turn your pain into feel
turn your failures into motivation
and never ever give up
the most dangerous word that you could
use
day to day is the word hope
hope this word keeps you poor think
about it when i talk to your
entrepreneur
when i ask them so what exactly is your
marketing strategy
they might say something like well dan
my marketing strategy is i build my
business
through word of mouth through referrals
and i always reply you mean hope you see
hope is not a strategy
most people they hope to grow their
business
they hope to get referrals they hope to
generate more income
they hope to have more free time they
hope to start their business
they hope they'll get bank financing for
the investments
they hope hope is not a strategy
you see successful people we don't use
hope as a strategy
because the minute you use the word hope
what you're saying is
you have no power you have no control
over
the outcome well i hope it works
i hope this works out now it's one thing
to say hey i hope you like this video
that's okay but whenever you say i hope
i when you give away that responsibility
you also give away that power you have
no control you have no
choice when you have no choice when you
have no control when you have no
power when you cannot decide you cannot
take action
and you cannot make that happen i can't
do it
right i i can't i i don't have time or i
can't afford it
it's the minute you use the word can't
your brain
stops working stops looking for
solutions
the minute you use i can't well that's
it i can't do it
right it rubs you off your potential it
rubs you off the possibility
instead ask yourself how can i
see when people say to me why i can't
start my business
or i can't develop that high income
skill or i
can do that side hustle or i can't
whatever
i always tell them does that mean that
you don't want to do it or does that
mean you don't know how to do it
because we all have the ability we can
all do something if we want to
could you do it if you really really
really want to
of course you could so the question is
it's not
i can't is either you don't want to and
that's perfectly fine
then don't say i can't just say i don't
want to
when your friends ask you to go out it's
just well you know i
can't tonight don't say i can't just say
you know what i've got other commitments
i don't want to go just tell them i
don't want to go this is not something i
want to do
or maybe next time right decide
commit when you say well i i i can't
does that mean you don't know how to do
it because you could go get the how-to
there's so much how-to on the internet
you could go find a way you can you can
take a program go to an event
learn from a mentor do something you
have the ability so
replace that word can't with either how
can i or hey you know what i can do it
i can start that business i can learn
that skill
i can learn from a mentor right i can
quit that job
i can go on their vacation you've got so
much
more potential if you just believe in
yourself let's take for example
that you want to start a shopify store
yes it kind of doesn't cost you a lot
but inventory costs you money so you
invest the last few thousand dollars you
have you go
all in into this particular venture
hopefully that it will work my question
is
what if it doesn't work what if the
product doesn't sell
you put all your life savings the little
bit of money that you have
into it and then now what what do you do
where do you go from here you see
instead of doing that and putting all
your eggs in one basket
the best thing you can do is start
investing in yourself
first invest in a skill set that you can
deliver to the marketplace in exchange
of money
this dramatically lowers your risk and
then when that is working then
you can start your business successful
people
embrace failures do you
embrace failures or do you take failures
personally you see successful people
they are
ridiculously positive about the future
they always speak positively about their
future
where things are going as if it's
already happened
even though there's no way that it could
happen they believe
in themselves right they have positive
expectations about
their future walt disney was fired by
news editors saying that he had no
imagination and no
creativity steven spielberg was rejected
three times
by film school before getting his huge
break colonel sander at the age of 56
got rejected a thousand times for its
recipe before a restaurant picks it up
you will notice the most successful
people in any field
they are usually the ones who have
failed more than anybody
else you see the difference between a
successful person
and everyone else is not a lack of
strength
it's not a lack of knowledge it's a lack
of
will winston churchill said it best
success is going from failure to failure
without losing enthusiasm you want to
get more customers we all
want more customers so we can generate
more revenue
now depending on your business type
you might have a two-step process
meaning you may not get a customer
directly
it may not be a direct sales scenario it
could be a two-step process where
you actually generate a lead maybe you
generate a lead online
and then you convert that lead into a
sale right it's a two-step process
so you have the lead generation process
and then you have the conversion process
it doesn't matter the bottom line is
that's what you focus on that's what
most
entrepreneurs focus on how do i get more
customers
the challenge is if you have been in
business for any length of time
that the biggest payoff sometimes the
highest
paid leverage points that you have
within your business may not be getting
more customers
because it costs a lot of money to
acquire customers nowadays right
when you're running traffic when you're
doing any kind of advertising it costs
a lot of money to acquire their first
initial customer
if you are a startup yes then focus on
getting customers because
you need customers to survive but if you
have been in business for a while
then i want you to consider some of the
other ways to increase
your revenue to grow your business
work for free are you a idiot
well that's one way to handle it when
someone asks you to work for free or
can i pay you later when you get results
for them but you can do it better than
that you can
deal with the objection with finesse
key word of the day comment below what's
the word finesse
it's like tai chi you want to redirect
don't fight force with force
redirect now remember i used to get this
objection
quite a bit when i was younger when i
was just starting out in my career right
when i don't have a track record then
people would ask me well dan i would i
would pay you
uh later when i get results or let's
let's try this out
or can you work for free like what the
[ __ ] am i like a volunteer right
i'm a business person here so what do
you do when you get that kind of
objection so
i'm gonna give you a couple ways to
handle this okay if you enjoy
this video give me a thumbs up remember
if you watch
a lot of my other videos i think you'll
love this video as well so here we go
number one it's easier to handle that
with
some kind of a metaphor and some kind of
a a question right a series of questions
and pick a picture in their mind so when
they say hey so can you work for free
you might say something like hey mr
prospect let me ask you a question here
let's say you want to buy a porsche and
you walk
up to a porsche dealership and you say
you know what i want to take this
poor sheer home and i'm going to drive
drive it for a month and just
see how i like it right and then maybe
come back and maybe i'll pay you
now if you are the the car dealership
you're the owner of this car dealership
what are you going to say to your
prospect like that
well i'm going to say no that's not how
it works oh no you're a good stupid
idiot
exactly right so that's a very powerful
way of using a metaphor
to handle it another way that i've used
a metaphor that's kind of an interesting
one
i would say hey mr prospect let me ask
you a question have you ever eaten a
restaurant before
yeah right so can you walk up to the
restaurant owner and say hey you know
what i'm gonna have
i'm gonna have the meal here and after
the meal i'm gonna go home i'm not gonna
pay i'm gonna go home and see
how i do in the bathroom let's see how
much
how i like it what kind of bowel
movement i have and then when i come
back
i'll see if i want to pay is that how it
works no that's not how it works at all
right like so there are different ways
you can handle in a
in a in a sarcastic but also firm and
respectful way
basically telling them indirectly that
you value
your time you're telling your prospect
you value your
skills and expertise right now in the
beginning maybe
you do have to do a little bit of work
pro bono
to get some experience that's not what
i'm talking about here we're talking
about closing
and asking for money up front right
we're signing a deal
we're signing an agreement and we're
trying to close a deal right here
right now if you want something done you
got to do it
yourself wow they'll never
do it as good as the way that i do it or
i don't trust him
or i don't trust her if you want
something done
you gotta do it yourself what you're
really saying is
i don't trust other people that is ego
there's a form of ego that holds you
back
because nothing great is accomplished
just with one person
it requires other people it requires
teamwork
so the do-it-yourself ego this is
probably one of the most
common egos that hold most people back
that hold
most entrepreneurs back that's holding
them back
from going to that next level because
they are control freaks
they have this massive massive
do-it-yourself
eagle that's holding them back my whole
life i've only had
one job in my entire life working at a
supermarket for
one year one day i walk into the
supermarket
my manager was yelling at me calling me
names
and i got so fed up with it i said hey
hey
hey you and i walked out i went home and
my mom saw me and she asked me oh how
come you got off work early what
happened i said no
i quit i don't want to work anymore it
is stupid
it's a waste of time and my mom was so
concerned
and so worried back then i was making
just
minimum wage with that job now do i
recommend that you do this
you walk into your manager's office your
boss often say hey i quit
i'm gonna now start a business i'm gonna
do something else
no because i put my mom
through hell i put myself through hell
looking back would i have done that i'm
not so sure
now i burn a ship i got that but what i
realized is
most people are not quite ready for that
or they don't have their
tenacity to make it happen just quite
yet
so if you're thinking about quitting if
you don't like what you do
and you're frustrated with the people
you work with or you don't like your job
you're not passionate about it
what you need to do is you need to have
some kind of a skill set
first what i call high income skill you
need to have a high income skill that
produces income for you before you quit
wouldn't be a smart idea because when
you quit today let me ask you this
how are you going to pay your bills how
are you going to get income coming in
how do you know the new thing that
you're doing is going to work
how do you know you don't know so a much
smarter way to approach this
is to develop your skill first so when
you have a skill that you are selling
you're offering to the marketplace
and you're actually getting paid you're
making money
and i believe the best way to do this is
when your high income skill
makes you twice as much money compared
to your current job that you have right
now
that's when you can quit then you can do
this
full-time the biggest thing that holds
most people back it's not the how-to
it's not to know what it's not don't
know what to do it's not the business
idea
it's the fact that they cannot operate
on their own being able to self-motivate
at the same time not having to get
permission from the people around them
that they wish how come don't you know
i'm doing this for you
how can my how come you guys don't
support me how come my family don't
support me how come they don't
understand
i don't get it i want to make more money
i want to be more successful
to better their lives how come they
don't understand guess what
most of time they will never understand
you're expecting something that that
won't happen
that's what's holding you back you're
expecting them to give you permission
yeah
go for the cheer you up no now the
question is why don't they support you
it's very simple it's very very simple
i go through this whole thing exactly in
my own life
first of all they don't understand
because most of us
we grew up in the miss educational
system where it's teaching you to behave
a certain way
go to school get good grades walk this
path get a degree
get a job work to 65 marry have kids
get a get a big mortgage that's your
life
anything that deviates from that
anything that's not the traditional path
that is stupid that is dangerous that is
wrong you shouldn't do that you should
do this
so the minute you want to walk a
different path you're
the people around you your loved ones
they feel like you're so
weird how come you can't do what
everybody else just
just be normal just settle just just
don't take risk play safe
get a safe secure job and the more you
deviate from that traditional path
the more they feel like they're the
bigger the distance between you and them
they're afraid to lose you they're
afraid that to lose you
they're afraid that you leave them
behind that's why
you don't have the support and all your
buddies or your friends
do you really think they want you to be
mega successful
to to live that dream life to travel
live in that beautiful home to drive
that car
that they could never afford do you
really think they want to be
that successful while they are living
paycheck to paycheck health
no they might say oh yeah we cheer for
you we
congratulations man good for you deep
down envineness
jealousy lower self it's human nature
so what i'm saying is don't don't even
expect it you're wasting your time
you do what you think is right you do
what you believe is right you walk your
own path
they might see it they might not see it
i'm not expecting to see it this is my
life it's not their life
i do what i know i need to do i was 20
years old
i just started my own one-man
cooperating agency
i was struggling to get clients one day
i was on the phone with
a prospect and about five and ten
minutes
into the conversation he said stop
i said what he said stop
he said five minutes into the
conversation you made
multiple grammatical errors
and you speak with an accent i don't
think i trust you to
write my copy and he said i think your
photo
and he hung up now at the time i was
already
feeling very insecure about english as
my second language
there's the first time in my life that i
felt rejected
i felt embarrassed humiliated
and i was so mad and so pissed off
first at the prospect how dare
he talks to me like that why does he
have to attack me like that
what did i do all i'm trying to do is to
make a living and provide for my mom
why does he call me names why does he
personally attack me like that
and then i made a decision the decision
that would forever change
my life i said to myself you know what
from now on i don't want to feel that
again
i'm going to work on my english i'm
going to work on myself
so that someday one day
not only are we able to speak
with clarity and conviction and
confidence
someday as a chinese as an asian
as an immigrant someday i will have
these guys pay
to hear me talk they would pay to hear
me speak
hear what i have to say and i did that
see how many times in your life
sometimes you feel rejected
there you feel people just why do people
reject you like this for no good reason
whatsoever maybe it's a job interview
maybe it's a business deal maybe it's in
relationship
your loved one your girlfriend your
boyfriend
that they break up with you and you feel
so rejected one thing i've learned
about rejection is it all depends on
perspective
sometimes let's say in business in sales
in closing
you have to deal with a lot of
rejections
in order to be successful you have to
talk to a lot of strangers
a lot of people saying no to you
if you want to make any significant
amount of money
but you see if you look at it that way
you will feel
defeated you feel rejected but if during
any closing goal for example
if you look at that there are three
things you will get out of it
number one you will get a yes which
means
you get a sale that's good number two
you could get a no
which is perfectly fine it simply means
you don't have to waste more time
with this prospect or number three for
sales that you don't close
you'll get a lesson you'll learn from it
you'll grow from it i want to think back
all those moments in your life
where you felt rejected i want you to
think back
doesn't that shape who you are today if
you think about it
those moments those incidents
those times where you felt so bad
but on those also some of the greatest
times without that incident
i wouldn't be where i am today there
will be no dan lok the other four words
that are very very dangerous that ruin
your life
is i can't afford it i only said that to
yourself how many said that maybe just
yesterday maybe just today
comment below i can't afford it
now this i learned from kiyosaki again
nothing new he talks about when people
say
i can't afford it again it just down
your brain
this there is no creativity required
when you say i can't afford it you want
something in your life i can't afford it
i want to buy that i can't afford it i
want to support my my parents i can't
afford it i won't take that vacation i
can't afford it i want to send my kids
to college i can't afford it
you see how it is i can't afford a
quarter i can't afford it it is an
easy way out because you're just making
excuse
so i can't afford it it requires no
effort that's a poor
person's mentality and you know this
poor people say that i can't afford it
what you think money grows on trees
somebody heard that before
comment below instead of saying i can't
afford it
ask yourself a powerful question and
that is
how can i afford it
how can i afford it the minute you ask
that
it opens up a world of possibility the
minute you change your vocabulary
instead of a statement a victim
statement
i can't afford it huh stop how can i
afford it
maybe i can't afford it with my current
job maybe i can't afford it with the way
that i'm conducting business
but how can i afford it what do i need
to do what
what knowledge do i need to acquire who
do i have to be
what new skill sets i need to develop in
order for me to afford
this you see how those questions are
much more powerful much more empowering
wouldn't you say so how can i afford it
when people come to and say hey dan i
want to make more money i always say
here you go here's a dime
you just made more money you see the
problem with an answer that is that
vague it doesn't give you power and
doesn't give you
clarity so it's not just about you know
i want to make more money how much
more money exactly do you want to make
and also
i always say it's not just how much
money you make
is how you make the money what would you
do for money what would you
not do for money where do you want to
live do you like
a big house you want a tank house do you
want to live in a condo or do you want
to live
in a penthouse you know what kind of car
do you drive
it's not good enough to just say oh i
want to drive a mercedes exactly
what color what model what upgrades do
you want
let me give you a perfect example i've
had multiple opportunities
come across my table where it would
require me to go to
asia and do more business in asia multi
multi multi million dollar opportunity
but in order to do that it will require
me to maybe stay here for six months in
canada
and then go to asia for six months a lot
of travel back and forth
and i asked myself hmm the money is good
but does it fit my lifestyle is this
something that i want and i said no
that's not something i want i prefer to
stay home i don't want to travel as much
so there you go what i will and what i
won't
do for money right where do you want to
travel
how often what hotels you want to stay
in what kind of charities do you want to
help
who do you want to help what kind of
investments do you want to own do you
like real estate
do you like stocks you like bonds mutual
funds whatever it is that you want to
invest in
that's clarity you cannot act and you
cannot take action
you cannot improve your financial
situation if you don't have
clarity lack of clarity means lack of
power and power is the ability to
take action extreme clarity
leads to extreme results today i'm going
to teach a concept called
the third door you see in any situation
there's
always someone or something when you can
meet that some person
it opens so many possibilities for you i
want you to imagine if you want to go to
a nightclub
okay you go to a nightclub you could
line up like everybody else right that's
the first store that
you are lining up and hopefully you
dress well if your lady can walk in
easily right
if you're a guy you got to weigh you got
to pay you got to you got to wait for
the bouncer if
the bouncer likes you then unless you
walk in or maybe you wait 2-3 hours
or if you are like the vip that you
spend the big
bucks right where now you are you get
you get a vip table you're spending big
money that's the second door
you could go in and you don't have to
wait in line like everybody else
but you're spending a lot of money now
the fourth door
the third door i'm talking about
something different where let's say you
get to be friend with the dj
that you know is gonna play at that
night or it's a very popular dj
and you befriend that dj let's say a
couple weeks in advance
and you get to know the dj now that's
the third door you get a club
without paying all this extra money
without
lining up you can kind of skip the line
and then because
you find that one person that can help
you
skip all the headaches they can skip
all the typical traditional way of
approaching someone
so once you think about your business
when you don't have that resources
when you don't know somebody don't let
that stop you what is where's the third
door
how can you find that person if you get
to meet that person it will open up the
door possibility for you
if you want to develop established
relationship with with powerful
successful people
here's what you do do not go up to them
and pitch your stuff
don't try to sell them your stuff okay
you have to understand when someone
comes up to me and say oh dan look at my
problems cause my thing
can you promote it you have to
understand what it sounds to me
it's like well dan you don't know me
but can you endorse me to your most
important clients and partners
it's no different if i walk up to the
street and i walk up to a beautiful
woman and say
your place or mine
but somehow in business it's okay
so here's what you do here's what you do
how is how you follow up here's how you
do what
let me give you a tip do not give them
your business card
it is not their job to follow up with
you
it is your job to follow up with them
they are already successful they have
what you want
why the hell will they follow with you
you think about it so don't give them
your business card here's what you do
ask for their contact information
and once you have that maybe a simple
email
and then you follow up and here's the
two questions you ask
two simple questions first question is
how can i learn more from you not to
pitch your [ __ ]
how can i learn more from you and second
he's my favorite what is the most
important project that you're working on
that i on my network can add value to
i'll say it again what is the most
important project
that i or my network can add value to
don't go up to people and say hey would
you like to buy my stuff
you need to do business with me write
this down needy is creepy
okay needy is creepy i always say that
your will
power is never as powerful as your
environment
a lot of times maybe you want to change
you want to make a new decision you want
to
take the leap of faith you want to do
something new but your environment is
not supportive of that
the people around you your family and
friends they are not
supportive of your new goal your new
vision that you have for yourself
or maybe in terms of your environment
where you live in there is not
supportive of
where you want to go so instead of
trying to fight with that i always say
change the environment
change your environment is much more
powerful because your environment is
more powerful than your
your willpower your your discipline so
what can you do to structure and create
that
environment so that it's easier for you
to accomplish
whatever it is that you want to
accomplish most of us live
up to other people's expectations we
don't want to disappoint
other people so let's use that don't
just rely on yourself
disciplined let's say you have a goal
instead of just keeping that to yourself
and say i'm going to work on that i'm
going to work on that and when i get
there then i'm going to tell other
people about it
no do the opposite do what i do tell the
whole world about it
declare to the whole world this is who i
am this is what i'm gonna do
this is who i want to be these are my
goals and you tell the whole freaking
word about it
the world will hold you accountable just
like my youtube channel
i declare in the beginning i'm gonna hit
a hundred thousand subscribers
we did that i declared the world we're
gonna hit a million subscribers
by the end of 2018 we did that
now we declare the world we're gonna hit
10 million subs guess what we're gonna
do that
i don't hide to myself and say oh i'm
just keeping to myself these are this is
my goal no i'm gonna tell the world
we're gonna do it we're gonna you and i
we're gonna do it together
it's the same thing
there's this village and the government
wants to develop
this village so they sent some of the
top agents to talk to
the chief of this village and these
agents they showed up to talk to the
chief and say hey
chief we are planning to spend millions
and millions of dollars building
infrastructure
helping you to develop this village and
achieve it's like
okay so what are you planning to do the
agents are saying you know what chief
here's what we're going to do
we are going to have some buses
we're going to send a lot of buses to
your village the chief is like okay so
why do we need buses well we're going to
have all these buses we're going to have
you we're going to educate you we're
going to bring your people and then
we're going to bring them to
a school the chief is asking well why do
we want to go to school
the agents are saying well when you go
to school you're going to study
different subjects and topics and so
that you could get a
a diploma or a degree the chief is like
okay so
what happens after we get the degree and
the diploma
oh then you'll be able to graduate
you're going to be able to find a safe
secure job and achieve it's like okay so
why do we want to save secure job
oh come on chief when you have that safe
secure job
then you're going to be able to make
some money you make some money then
you're going to
you can have kids your people are going
to have kids and then they can get a
house
okay so and then the chief's like okay
and then what oh then you get a house
and you put aside
some some money and then you work many
many many years until you're 65
and guess what chief and you get retired
and the chief is like okay then what
happens after retirement
what do you mean what happens after we
time it after with time you can do
whatever you want
you can go fishing you can spend time
with your family
you can go hunting you can do whatever
you want
the chief looks at the agents and saying
i'm doing that right now
i'm fishing and hunting and spending
time with my family right now why didn't
you go through all this process
the moral of the story is this that
sometimes we are
chasing we're so focusing on the goals
and we
sometimes forget why do we want those
things
in the first place is what i believe
it's a very important lesson i want to
share with you
it's not just how much money you make
it's how you make
the money knowing that money just a
vehicle is a mean to an end
at the end of the day what is it that
you're after look at richard branson
richard branson gets a minimum of one
hundred thousand dollars
to do a speech to deliver a talk
now why do people pay richard branson a
hundred thousand dollars
just to do a talk because he is a
celebrity authority now you may be
thinking
no but then he's a billionaire of course
he gets paid a hundred thousand dollars
that is not true because there are a lot
of billionaires out there
don't get paid a hundred thousand
dollars to do a speech richard branson
does
because he is a celebrity authority
look at oprah what business you think
she's in now you might be thinking oh
she
owns a tv network we all know that she's
a tv personality
she owns the magazines that's not true
oprah is in the business of oprah
oprah is in the celebrity authority
business you look at most people the
biggest
personal brands in the world they're all
in the celebrity authority business
you see most struggling entrepreneurs
they spend way too much time
working on the what how could i be a
better
coach how could it be a better digital
marketer how could it be a better
copywriter instead what you need to work
on is working on the who
everybody's spending time working on the
what you are not spending enough time
working on the who
who you are who you want to be known
almost everyone spends way too much time
working on the what and not enough time
working
on the who who you are
you see at the highest income level you
don't get paid for what you do
you get paid for who you are you
want to get fit you want to
be healthier where you want to lose
weight now what are some
things you can do you could go and buy
one of those you know gadgets and
machines that you see on on tv
right and then you buy it and and then
you that gets delivered to your home
and you use it for a couple days and
very quickly
they become what i call expensive dust
collectors right
or expensive like clothes hanger you
know one of those
machines and running machines right
you're just sitting in your bedroom
sitting in your living room or you can
say oh i'm gonna sign up for a gym
membership
and you know how it works you sign up
for a gym membership maybe you go a
couple times and then you stop going and
then
oh yeah i'll go next week and i'll go
next week i'll go next week
no one is holding you accountable you
cannot even hold yourself accountable
and then guess what but you signed a
three-year contract you sign a two-year
contract
but you end up not using that gym
membership now imagine a different
scenario
where yes you're gonna lose weight
but you're gonna hire some people you're
gonna surround yourself
with people who hold you accountable who
keep you accountable so let's say you
hire personal trainer
and you know that personal trainer is
costing you whatever
thirty dollars fifty dollars eighty
dollars whatever that it costs
you the personal trainer trains with you
comes up with a some kind of a meal plan
and
and some kind of exercise planned for
you well
guess what chances of you doing what it
takes
that probability goes up rich people
we value time more than we value money
poor people they value money more than
they
value time and that's why if there's
something
with my bentley and oil change or i
gotta go do something or fix the car
i'm not gonna do it because it's not
worth
my time my time is much more valuable i
have other activities that i could do
that could bring in more money now you
may be saying that while easy for you to
say
you're dan lok you've got money of
course you could do that
that is not true you might be thinking
because you are rich that is not true
i got rich when i started valuing
my time most people never get rich
because they never
value their time once i started learning
and i started having more success and
making a few dollars i was i was
becoming more arrogant i was becoming
more
you know that i felt i was invincible
that oh now i'm so
smart look at look at look at me and and
of all this money coming in
and and i was way more successful than
every all the people around me right
and i thought you know what my [ __ ]
doesn't stink i thought
i was the man right and invest in a
bunch of companies
well guess what all uh 10 companies all
of them lost money not
one of them made money and it wasn't so
invincible anymore
and that got me into into quite a bit of
trouble
so that's what i would say don't don't
be arrogant get out of your ego
be humble stay humble be open-minded you
can learn something from
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
ah don't be such a loser
thank me later
[Music]
include a damn room look at kim
kardashian
it shows you you don't need talents to
make money
you just need to get well is she a great
singer
is she a great actress what the [ __ ]
does she do
she gets attention yes and people pay
for their attention
most businesses fail write this down
because
they are not getting enough attention in
the marketplace if you want to grow your
revenue you want to grow your brand you
want to grow your company
you must get attention you must
get attention attention
is a new currency money follows
attention
think of whatever products and services
in your marketplace in your industry
that
are there products and services that are
maybe less quality
than what you're offering but they're
selling more how many have seen that
before
yes why because they're committed those
companies
even though they have a less quality
product service they're committed to
getting attention you got to get it out
there
you got to push your name because
there's so much noise i hear people
but then i put on like one tweet you
know
on one facebook how come orders don't
come rolling
in because it's one pause
don't think in terms of one not one
tweet
ten tweaks a hundred tweaks
a thousand tweaks i'm at the tokyo
skytree
you see one of the things that i love
japan about the japanese culture
is their dedication to mastery see the
other day i was walking down the street
in japan
and i saw this gentleman probably 70 80
years old
and he's running his restaurant is
preparing the
supplies and waking up early in the
morning
and just getting ready to do what he
does probably has been doing it for
many many decades many many years yeah
he has a smile on his face
you see that is absolutely incredible
because when you think about it in the
north american culture you know what i'm
talking about that we are sometimes very
impatient
that we want something immediately that
i think we don't dedicate enough
time to mastery that we don't dedicate
enough time to master
something in our lives and most people
struggle financially you notice
they jump from one thing to another they
try a little bit there's a little bit of
that a little bit of this a little bit
of that
extremely distracting and they don't
focus on that one thing
so how do you master anything how do you
master
a skill except dedication you see in
japan
it doesn't matter if they are making
chopsticks it doesn't matter
matter if they are running a restaurant
it doesn't matter if they're making
noodles
it doesn't matter they're making shoes
chances are sometimes they've been doing
that for generations
that their father did the same thing and
they're running a small business
and they don't look upon what they do
it's just oh here's a job that i'm doing
that
oh man it's a j-o-b no it is their
career they take pride in what they do
even making a little dessert you can see
the dedication the effort
the thoughtfulness that go into it i
think that's something that
i find it not just fascinating but
something very
much i admire it's something that i
think we can all learn from
you have to understand that when it
comes to mastery you don't get it
overnight
it takes time you don't build this
overnight
it takes years and years and years
of dedication that mastery
there's no shortcut how can you be of
service
and give back to others you see success
is not about what you get it's about
what you give
and i don't just mean giving stupidly i
mean giving strategically
giving help giving back to others who
deserve
your help and not everyone deserves your
help but you can find
that brilliance where it's something
that you enjoy doing
non-stop it is what you are good at what
comes easy to you
at the same time it is a service of
others and that you can impact other
people and give
back to others then life is easy life is
good
because you love doing it and naturally
if you are good
and you love doing it naturally you will
get good right and when you get good
you'll be able to help more people see
this is something i learned the hard way
because
for the first 10 years of my business
career let's say from my 20s to
my 30 years old when i'm just building
my empire i was all about me me me me
i know what it's like it's all about you
know how can i make the most amount of
money
right how how can i grab all the chips
on the table
there's no win-win is only win lose and
i want to win and you're going to lose
and i did that and i made quite a bit of
money
but something was missing something
wasn't
working until i learned that it's not
life it's not just about yourself
when you can integrate your strength
what you're good at
and you can impact other people life
becomes much more interesting
not to mention when you make it about
others guess what money comes to you so
easily
so effortlessly so in order to be
successful
yes hard work has its
place a lot of people work hard but it's
not
enough it's not just it's part of the
equation
but it's not the only factor i believe
to be
successful in life or in business you
need to find
what i call your brilliance that's right
your brilliance what comes easy for you
but it's hard for others what comes
easy for you what are your strengths
what are you naturally good at not not
necessarily just
physically but it could be what skills
do you have
what is easy for you because sometimes
we take it for granted
what is easy for you may not be so easy
for others
you see sometimes people talk about the
concept of you got to work on your
weaknesses i don't believe in that i
believe if you work on your
weaknesses at the end of your life you
will have guess what a lot of strong
weaknesses i believe in life it is about
finding and identifying your strengths
and put your effort
to make your strengths stronger
focus on a couple things that you are
good at
and how can you make that stronger and
offer that to the marketplace
in exchange of money to render a
service that's what works think about
desire versus skills desires versus
skills
you might have the desire to be
successful and that's cool
you have the desire i am interested i
want to buy a new home
i want to pay off my debt i want to help
my mom
i want to buy that new car but if you
don't have the skill sets to back it up
that is nothing you have a desire but if
you don't have the skills
you'll always be frustrated it's
perfectly fine you can follow people on
instagram
you follow me on facebook and you look
at their life and that's all cool
you have the desire but unless you have
the skill sets unless you back it up
with your skills it's not going to work
so what skills i'm talking about i'm
talking about skills of marketing
i'm talking about skills of selling
skills of closing
skills of revenue generation how to
manage your time
skills of personal self-management
skills of
time management all these excuses that
you must develop
if you want to be wealthy so you have a
choice you could have your desires
and those skills and you'll be
frustrated for the rest of your life
or you have to desires and combined with
skill sets now you've got something
now you can back it up now you can
create the life that you want
how do you achieve work life balance how
do i run a global
organization be able to travel with
japan for
20 days with jenny right and also
be able to create content and impact
millions of people
in the world while maintaining sanity
how do you do that well the key question
is not so much
work-life balance but work-life
integration
i want you to think about back then when
you were a little kid the balance swing
that you played
you have two kids one on this side one
on this side and they're playing this
kind of see-saw right in order to have
momentum
in order to have fun with the game what
they have to do
it's always like this imagine the
balance swing is perfectly balanced
perfectly steel what would happen
the thing won't be moving you won't be
having any momentum
that is exactly like life if you're
perfectly balanced
you will have no momentum and you're not
going anywhere
what you need to do is you think about
what is important for me what's my
priority
because you cannot achieve greatness
remember
great success requires great effort
anything that requires
great effort you cannot say oh i'm gonna
have a perfect body
i'm gonna have a perfect family life i'm
gonna have a lot of free time
and i want to build something great it
doesn't work that way
something has to give you have to
sacrifice there's a pay price to action
what are you willing to give up to get
what you want see one of the key
questions that i ask myself is
when i was getting started what is the
one goal that if i could accomplish that
would get me everything else would get
me all the other goals
and i knew i had to focus on money first
because when i get money out of the way
i can focus on what's
important in my life now i'm not saying
be a workaholic
and i'm not talking about money is
everything i'm talking about i need to
sacrifice
some of my other priorities what is that
one thing if i accomplish that
everything else
would work i pick business because i
knew when i get the money out of the way
when i made
my fu money everything would work much
easier
then you can have more balance it's not
so much balance
so even when i'm traveling guess what
i'm making a video for you
right with my team it's not balance it's
work-life integration
how do you integrate what you do into
your daily life
now imagine you're a golfer someone
asked you how do you balance
golf with your family life
you would say well what are you talking
about i'm a golfer
i play as much golf as possible
and i've learned golf things in my life
because i am a
golfer that's exactly what i'm talking
about when you are an entrepreneur
when you're a go-getter when you are an
influencer
that is work-life integration what you
do with your life
and your work they are very blurry that
line is very very blurry
and that's exactly what i'm talking
about so forget this work life
balance both focus on work life
integration
how to integrate your life how to
integrate with your work
how to integrate all the debt with what
you do that's the secret
to having that work-life balance and
communication skills come in many forms
i'm talking about writing their email
or writing their social media posts or
conducting that meeting
or speaking one-on-one speaking on the
phone talking with a prospect
or even speaking to large groups of
people
all those falls under communication
skills
one of the things that i did that
changed my life early on in my career is
i joined toastmasters
to hone and develop my public speaking
skills
i was also learning from a mentor to
develop my
copywriting skill which is communication
in the
written forms how to use words in print
to persuade influence
somebody so all successful people they
have this one thing in common
the ability to influence persuade
inspire
other people do you worry how people
perceive you
you know you want to do something but oh
what would people think of that
what would people think of my action
even deep down you know
that's the right thing to do but you
don't do it because you have
other people's opinions ego you let
other people's opinions
stop you from doing what you know is
the right thing those people they could
be your family
they could be your relatives they could
be your friends they could be your high
school buddies it doesn't
matter it could be social media you're
uploading a video you're posting on
social media you're making noise
you're getting attention suddenly you
get a few haters guess what you stop
people don't care about you haters and
trolls who add no value in your life
and some keyboard warriors some losers
post a comment and you're like
oh i guess that hurts my feeling and you
stop
doing what it's right you stop doing
what is going to make you
successful stop
stop worrying about other people's
opinions
it's just their opinions just doesn't
matter
critics haters haters gonna hate it
doesn't
matter you do what you know it's right
one of the things that i do when it
comes to bringing new people
on board and that could be an employee
could be a contractor
it could be a salesperson it could be
any of the roles that you might have
what i like to do is imagine
that that person is a jockey how do you
know if they're jockeying
perform well in a race what i do is i
would always give them a lame
horse first that's right a lame horse
i'll give you a perfect example
so one of the key team members that we
have now blake who is my director
first he comes in the company he wants
to help me to boost my
instagram followers at the time i only
had a few thousand
followers on instagram so i wasn't
paying a lot of attention to it i'm like
i was a little bit skeptical would this
work would this not work
and blake came up with this amazing
proposal and plan i said okay
run with it now in the beginning i
didn't give him a lot of resources
i didn't give him any more power i said
do what he could i gave him very very
little
he was asking me to even get some new
photos for instagram i said no
take whatever i have see what you can do
and he was able to
do so much with so many people to grow
the instagram following as well as
generate revenue for the company with
very very little resources now that's a
lame
horse right gave a good jockey a lame
horse
see how far he could go right and
afterwards i say okay
this is pretty good let me give you some
more resources
my high school geography teacher told me
why can't you pay attention
why you're so stupid you'll never amount
to anything in your life i'm gonna fail
you in this course
my manager at my first job you dirty
robbing good for nothing
breaking your [ __ ] floor you'll
be lucky if you ever get a job at
mcdonald's
i don't have a lamborghini i'm not
interested in a lamborghini
my favorite the ae86
the ae86 represents the classic
underdog story who punches above its
weight class
and showing the world that you don't
need an expensive car you'll need a
powerful car
to win a race the character kakumi
it's every opponent that comes his way
with precision with skill and
the ae86 my whole life
people telling me well dan you can't do
this you can't do that
you can't immigrate to a foreign country
and start all over again
you can't drop out of college and be a
success
you can't start your own business you
have no business degree
you can't do copywriting you've learned
english twice when you win high school
you cannot start a business on the
internet no one
makes money on the internet you can't be
a millionaire
you can't be a multi-millionaire you
can't become a best-selling author no
one would buy your book
who do you think you are you can't hit
10 000 subscribers on youtube
nobody watches your video you can't hit
a hundred thousand subscribers on
youtube
you can't hit a million subscribers on
youtube you can't feel a global
organization using
social media you see in life there will
always be haters there will always be
doubters there will always be
non-believers and then there will be you
proving them wrong if you're serving a
local market if you are
making money and generate income from
just working with and serving people in
your city
expand that so instead of focusing a
local market
how can you take what you do and offer
to a more global market so
when this economic downturn in your
country and i know our fans in
you know over the world in your country
or in your city
you're not depending on it when you are
serving
people in so many different countries
right because usually
when there's a economic downturn in this
country this is booming right
if there's there's a problem with this
country right and this is booming
so instead of focusing on a local market
serve
a global market have you had moments in
your life
when you feel like you just want to give
up
that no one is coming to help you
no one is coming to rescue you then
you've tried everything you possibly
could
to solve the problem that's in front of
you
and just feel like quitting
i've had many many of those moments in
my life
and in my career
[Music]
as an entrepreneur i faced various
challenges competitions problems
on a day-to-day basis and there are many
times in my life that i felt
[Music]
maybe i couldn't solve this problem
maybe i couldn't overcome this
maybe i should just quit i'm not gonna
give you some rah-rah motivational talk
and say hey
just don't give up just hang in there
just don't give up what i am gonna do
is to share with you some of the things
i've learned
when i've gone through a lot of ups and
downs in my business career to get to
where i am
today that what do you do when you feel
like you want to quit
when you feel like quitting what do you
do
you see whatever that's in front of you
whatever obstacle
that's in front of you right now and you
feel like
you have done everything you possibly
could that
yes i have tried everything
to overcome this my question to you is
have you tried everything
[Music]
have you talked to enough people have
you read all the books that you could
on this topic have you seek mentorship
have you seek help have you done
everything you
possibly could have you taken all the
actions that you possibly could
to overcome this have you my guess is
probably not because if you have you
would have already gotten the results
you see it's never a matter of lack of
resources
it's always a lack of resourcefulness
that you're not created enough that we
are not created enough
that we don't think outside the box
enough and sometimes when you get so
close so close to your goal a lot of us
we just give up we quit when we are
disclosed
to achieving that goal you see success
is on the razor's edge of failure
when you think it couldn't get any worse
when you think it couldn't be worse than
what you're going through
right now when you think it couldn't be
any tougher
that's when breakthrough happens
sometimes in life you break down before
you break through
learning from your peers is sometimes
you learn the wrong thing
they kind of they tell you it is a mess
this is a disaster right it's just back
and forth back and forth
live service think about anyone who is
like athletic
they want to be an athlete they want to
be a gymnast
they want to be a basketball player they
want to be a football player
you love don't look at anybody how many
hours they train every day
you look at anyone who's like at the
forgetting olympic level anyone who's
like at the professional level
how many hours they have to swim every
day look at michael phil how many hours
years and years and years and that's why
they're the very best of what they do
there's no such when you there's no such
thing when you
just when you put your energy in four
five six things something it's got to
give
something's got to give you can't versus
if you focus on this
you will never get to this point when
your energy is like like that
you can only get at this point when it's
like this this is single focus
but when you focus on this by the time
they say you're 20 years old
you're living like this you're making
six figure a year your friend is like
dude it would take them
i don't know 10 15 20 even 30 years
might never even get to that point
ever ever just think about that
so you want to pay the price early or
you don't want to pay the price
late do you know how to close can you
articulate the value of
what you do to your potential clients
do you know how to ask powerful
questions that compel
people to buy are you comfortable
talking to
strangers presenting your ideas
demonstrating your product or service
closing skill
i believe is one of the most important
if not
the most important skills you need to
master if you want to be rich
when you're talking to customers you're
closing when you're talking to
vendors trying to persuade them to give
you better terms guess what you are
closing
when you're talking to your employees
you are
closing i think there are many many
opportunities we can take advantage of
but i think in life there are only
certain moments where
you accomplish more in seven months than
you've
accomplished in last seven years it's a
very different kind of opportunity right
so when you have those opportunities you
recognize i
will be able to accomplish more in these
seven months
than what i've done in the last previous
seven years you got to recognize hey
this is one of those
opportunities i better not [ __ ] this up
i better not let this slip through my
finger
right it's a very different thing but
people don't they don't have the
awareness to recognize
this is what that is right how do you
know
like like do you just feel it or you
would feel it and you would know
it's very simple you know hey you know
what if this
is just like the internet back then yeah
if this is what i think it is and this
goes the way that i think it would go
holy sh like where would i be
right that's all i could think about
right the first mentor if
if i could learn a skill if i could i
wasn't even thinking about it but if i
could
learn the skill high income skill or
copywriting and that would take me
at least off this treadmill because i
was not making money my business were
losing money i wasn't going anywhere my
mom wasn't paying my mom like taking
care of my mom
but then what i need to do so if this
works and i could have someone that i
could go to
like i would take advantage of them and
that's exactly what happens right
because i was making
like next to no money to making 10k
within one year
like it doesn't take a rocket scientist
right to figure that out and then from
there
because i'm in the industry consulting
and then speaking it just
branches out from there and then when i
took the skill went on the internet
i'm like wow this is like there's no
competition this is crazy
that i'm able to get in this early back
in 2004
right like wow i wasn't even thinking
about
there's no competition no one is like
marketing a ton
online and then i was selling like
ebooks and stuff like that
way before ebook was popular right or
selling it in
a exe file because that back then you
don't have pdf
you need to how do you have a software
in order to read the ebook
floppy disk no no no but they need to
download software in order to
to read the ebook right and it's like
this type of stuff
so that's what i mean i don't think in
life we get more than three
like if you you get this done you
accomplish this goal it gets you
everything else
what is this thing you get this you get
everything else
right you really help your mom pay off
the debt buy the car
get the girlfriend get everything else
to
get this done everything gets done then
why don't i need to worry about this i'm
going to worry about this i just need to
worry about this
then i get everything else but what most
people do oh maybe i did this a little
bit like this
a little bit try to catch everything i'm
like holding it with two hands
like i'm like i'm so focused and that's
why my
life you see even today like really no
joke
why i'm only good at a couple of things
maybe handful things
everything else i'm like useless you
know like the most basic
thing in life like cooking or i don't
know how to do it because i never spend
a minute of my time
on those things i don't know how to turn
on the laundry machine i just don't know
i don't know how it works because i've
never done it all my focus is on this
nothing else i block out everything else
and just this
all these day-to-day stuff doesn't
matter michael gerber from e-myth talks
about this
most people they're actually not
entrepreneurs they are technicians
suffering from an entrepreneurial
seizure meaning that they're very good
at the technical work
at the thing but they don't understand
how the business
works they do not know how to sell
see the number one skill that you need
as an entrepreneur
as a business owner is the ability to
close
if you don't close sales you will not
bring in revenue and with no revenue
you don't have a business and yet most
people they get into business without
developing that skill set most people
don't know how to communicate
viewer know how to sell almost no one
knows how to close
when you can close anyone at any time
it means that you have the ability to
generate revenue
at any moment then you can create
revenue for your company
and that is the number one skill that
you need to make sure that your
business is successful successful people
are confident in their abilities you see
the two biggest enemies to success
number one self-doubt number two fear
of the unknown we struggle with
self-doubt we worry are we ready for
this
are we good enough do we actually have
what it takes to succeed
confidence is nothing more than
believing in
yourself and believing in yourselves is
nothing more than doing the things that
you once
didn't believe that you could do you see
confidence
comes from competence it's easy to
believe in yourself when everyone
believes in you that's not what i'm
talking about
i'm talking about believing in yourself
when you're not ready
believing in yourself when no one
believes you believe in yourself when
everyone doubts you that you cannot do
it then you cannot make it that you
don't have what it takes
that is when you need to develop that
unshakable self-confidence that believe
that
you can do it and confidence is not the
same
as arrogance the arrogance is thinking
that you're above
everybody else confidence is knowing
that no one is
above you do you feel confident
enough in your own abilities that you
can do what it takes are you willing to
bet on yourself not just words but
action how often you invest in yourself
are you willing to put everything you
have on the line
for your goals and for your dreams do
you bet on yourself
or do you procrastinate do you hesitate
are you perfectionist do you suffer from
paralysis analysis
be very very careful who you select as a
partner
you cannot do a good deal with a bad
partner
i've had a few really a few partnerships
in my life and the ones that are good
they are very very very good we have a
good relationship
we make a lot of money together we we
create a lot of success
together but the handful that are bad
they hurt me
tremendously one one bad partner that i
that i had actually had to
to a point where we were fighting he
stole my customers
and i had to actually shut down the
company and start a new one and
clean up everything that i have set up a
new entity
walk away with a lot of money just
because
of the bad partners that i had so
a good partner is great but you cannot
do a
good deal with a bad partner in fact you
can i would rather do and do an okay
average deal
but with a great partner because with a
great partner we're resourceful
we we collaborate we we mastermind we
work together
and that i mean that we can turn any bad
deal into
into it into a good deal the one word
that holds you back from success is
exactly
that word someday you see unsuccessful
people
they say someday someday i
will take that vacation someday i would
pay off that debt
someday i would quit my job someday i
would start that business
someday i would be able to provide for
my family it's always some day and
someday
think about in business if you say to
yourself someday i
will get that customer someday i would
close that sale
how much money have you made zero
none i want to look at your calendar
from monday tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday sunday i want to look at
your calendar
where is someday it doesn't
exist it is a made-up thing
that we do to procrastinate there is no
someday on your calendar it doesn't
exist
so unsuccessful people they use someday
successful people use today
today is going to be the day today i'm
going to take action
today i'm going to make it happen today
i'm going to close that cell
today is the day that i'm gonna make
[ __ ] happen i'm gonna get
done write this down procrastination
equals poverty procrastination
equals poverty you see unsuccessful
people it's always
oh yeah i'll do it later i'll do it
tomorrow
i'll do it someday successful people
would say today you see when you use the
word someday
why is this so destructive it's simply
this
when you use the word someday you might
think it makes
you look noble on the outside
because you are putting off your dreams
your goals
right you're making a excuse because
simply saying well someday because
i am not ready so someday i will do that
later
and some day never comes and you'll
never be ready
you don't need to be ready to do
something
you don't have to get it right you just
have to get it
going you do not have to get it right
you just need to get it going
it doesn't exist it makes you look noble
on the inside when you
think and you lie to yourself that is
the
responsible thing to do that i'm not
ready i don't want to take any risk
i don't want to take any chances when it
is the most selfish
and irresponsible thing that you can do
to yourself
and to your family it doesn't exist
eliminate that word from your vocabulary
either say you know what i'm gonna do
today or i'm not gonna do it i remember
the first
five years when i was building my
empire building my business the first
five years
i was working i did not take a single
day off
for five years strict i was working
every single day
12 to 14 hours i remember there were
nights where i actually
literally worked to exhaustion and i
fell asleep
on my desk that's the price that i paid
while all my friends they were drinking
partying
watching sports game and then chase and
girls
i didn't do any of that i was focused i
was obsessed because i was
willing to pay for the prize for success
i was committed
to spend a few years doing whatever
it takes doing things that other people
are not
willing to do making sacrifices that
other people are not willing to make
so that i could do what i want to do for
the rest of
my life what about you how bad do you
want it
what's the price you are willing
to pay and one of the most common things
i
see that haters critics are posting is
dan lok is a scam he's a scam artist
it's a fraud
in order for me to quote unquote scam
you
i will need something from you which i
don't please don't do me any favor
don't buy my books don't buy my course
don't don't even watch my
video don't don't do me any favors do me
a favor don't watch my stuff
i don't need anything from you i don't
need a penny from you
ever i don't even want you to to buy
anything please
let me know your name i'll put you on
the list so to make sure my team knows
i won't i don't please do not spend a
penny with me
i do not want anything from you i have
everything i need i have everything i
want
the reality is this the biggest scam in
human history is
you've already been scammed if you're
over 25 years old
if you're honest if you have nothing in
your bank account
you have no money you're not living your
dreams you got nothing
to show for you've already been scammed
you have
nothing zero you've been scammed
you've been scammed by the school system
you've been scammed
by the society you've been scammed by
the government you've been scammed by
the corporation
you have nothing you've already been
scammed
no one can take anything from you
because you got nothing for them to take
you got to think about it you've been
scammed by your preconceived ideas
of how things should work but not
actually how it works
wake up look at the world as it is
not as how you think it should be
whenever people want to make a change
they want to change their lives they
don't want to follow the traditional
path
go to school get good grades get a job
work till you're 65.
hopefully with little luck you can
retire
anyone who deviates from that path
they're crazy they are stupid why are
you doing that
it is risky anyone anything
any course that teaches people how to do
that
it's a scam it has to be a scam
so when i charge a tiny little bit of
money for what i teach
that's a scam when in school system that
you spend 10
20 30 50 a hundred thousand dollars or
more
to get a school education and you spend
four years you get into student loan
if that's you comment below share your
story and somehow after you graduate
maybe you get a degree maybe you get two
degrees
and you cannot even get a [ __ ] job
you cannot even survive
you cannot pay your bills you're still
hundreds of thousand dollars in debt
[Music]
that's perfectly normal that's the way
to go
and still people are telling you your
parents are telling you
that's the way to go your friends are
telling you yep just stay on the path
are you stupid can't you see it is not
working master don't dabble
master don't dabble master don't dabble
a lot of entrepreneurs they have this
what i call shiny object syndrome
okay it's oh it's it's social media it's
it's periscope it's twitter it's
facebook
it's whatever flavor of the week or
flavor of the month they never take the
time to master anything
focus on one thing and build on the next
master one in my career
i focus on building one skill first and
then build the next first i focus on
marketing then i focus on internet
marketing then i focus on management
leadership then i focus
on on deal making investing but one
thing at a time
so my approach is more like this most
entrepreneurs approach is like this
you got to build build one thing be
successful and then work on it
what do you do if you don't want to be
an entrepreneur let me tell you about my
friend ron
now i've known ron for almost 10 years
now
he is one of the highest paid
photographer
in my city it takes a lot of different
photos
one of the most expensive in my city now
he doesn't have a business
he's simply a photographer what ron has
is a high income skill if you follow my
work you know
i believe in the power of having that
high income skill
and i define a high income skill as a
skill that can make you a minimum
10 000 a month 10k a month 120
000 a year or more so ron has a high
income skill which
is a high-end photographer now he's a
very frugal guy remember back then
he could have bought a a place a house
in burnaby he's making very good money
but he bought a very modest home not for
a lot of money
and him and his wife and two kids
living there and he as he keeps making
more and more money
he put aside and save those money and
put into real estate
he started off buying smaller property
fixing them flipping them
selling them eventually moving into
duplex
bigger bigger units and today
after all these years he owns over 200
units in vancouver now if you know
vancouver real estate
it is one of the most expensive in the
world so he owns
apartment buildings he owns commercial
properties
doors 200 units he doesn't have a
business
he is not a business owner over the
years he all he has is he has developed
his high income skills
he has maximized his high income skill
and he takes that money and put it into
high return investments
in this case real estate that's it he's
now worth
tens of millions of dollars it's
basically retired
traveling with the wife and traveling to
all kinds of countries just enjoying
life
because every month it's got rental
income coming in right
so i want you to think about you don't
need to be an entrepreneur
to be successful financially what you
need to
absolutely that you need is high income
skills
number one smart entrepreneurs they
never
micro manage now i want you to imagine
back then when you are starting your
business
now i remember when i was starting my
first few businesses
i was a control freak where i was the
king
of micro management i wouldn't know all
the details
because in the beginning of your career
your business career
you are doing everything you are the
one-man one-woman show you are selling
you are closing you are doing the
invoice you're doing the marketing
you're meeting with people you are doing
the fulfillment you're taking the phone
call you're dealing with the receipts
right
and you are trying to make sure
everything don't fall apart you're
talking to everybody
and you have to micromanage because
that's what you need to do
but after a certain point that behaviors
even as you grow
stay because that's how you know
that's what it takes to grow a business
i got to know everything i got to
micromanage
but then what happens is as your revenue
grows
you will hit a glass ceiling and that
behavior
as a rugged individualist as a control
freak
does not serve you if you want to go to
the next level you have to let go
now you can no longer manage
in a small details kind of way you
cannot micromanage anymore
so smart entrepreneurs you have to learn
and we know
we are macro thinkers what we need to do
as a smart entrepreneur is we need to
figure out exactly
where we are going what's our vision
that's your job
you figure out the vision number one and
number two you now recruit and hire
talents to help you that you know they
have
the capabilities and the right attitudes
the right culture to help you
to execute that vision that's number two
and number three
you as a leader very important
allocate the resources their capital to
execute that vision to help your team
execute that vision that is it
that is it when you are micromanaging
you cannot do that
because you're too close to your
business you got to step back and think
about the big picture
what is the vision who do i need to have
on my team to execute this vision
and how do i allocate my resources that
will help them
prioritize they will help my team to
execute that vision and that is it
so small entrepreneurs we don't
micromanage you have to understand the
world
revolves around value
so if you understand the world revolves
around
value the business of making money
is nothing more than a value and value
exchange once you realize that that is
how money works and that's how the game
works so what we do is we trade
our time if you're an employee our
products or services
our expertise as an entrepreneur right
our skills
we trade that and exchange that with
other people
for money what it means is the more
value that you could provide the more
money people are willing to trade you
with it
it's that simple so instead of just
focusing on i want to make more money i
want to make more money
being all desperate and all panicking
what you focus on is instead of becoming
a person of
success become a person of value
if you want to make more money the
question you have to constantly ask
yourself is
how could i be a person of value how
could i become
more valuable how do you become
more valuable to the marketplace once
you understand this
money is not an issue because the
marketplace
is always always willing to pay good
money
for good value and you notice people who
don't make a lot of money
people who are struggling or people
making minimum wage they
are easily replaceable this is someone
working
at at a restaurant a waiter waitress
maybe they good they do very good job
they work very hard
but if they leave or the boss the
manager fires them
they could be easily replaced when you
could be easily replaced
you are not very valuable the more
difficult you are
to replace the more valuable you are
that's the secret
they will guarantee if you'll be broke
or you'll be
rich what do you do when others don't
support you
in your life it reminds me of the story
there's this fishman and he goes out
there to the sea and he would
catches these buckets of crap and one
man walks by and sees that he's got this
bucket right and there's no lid and the
the man is asking this fisherman well if
when you catch different crabs aren't
you afraid that why don't you have a lid
on the crabs gonna crawl out and the
fishman is like yeah if i have one crab
that one crab will crawl out however if
i have a bunch of crabs
no i don't need to worry about it
because they will make sure that that
any single crab tries to crawl out the
other crabs would pull that crab
right back down with with where they are
inside the bucket that's the the theory
that the
the story of the buckets of crap guess
what you have a lot of crap people
in your life they try to pull you down
they try to drag you down
to try to keep you where you are today
they don't want you to get out of that
bucket now why
is that you have to understand if you
are seeking
validation you're seeking approval you
are
waiting for someone else's permission
where
yeah you know it would be nice i want to
accomplish all these great things
i want to do these things and i want to
you know create all these things i want
to achieve all these goals
but uh but the people around me they
just
they don't support me so what don't
expect them to support you that's not
their job to support you if you need the
emotional support
to do what you do you don't have what it
takes you see you don't have to be the
marketing genius your customer
is the marketing genius they will tell
you what they want
they will tell you what they like and
they would also tell you what they don't
like
and what are they willing to pay for
they vote with their
wallets and that's the best bet you see
most entrepreneurs they spend so much
time
working on the thing or making their
thing
better but they don't spend enough time
listening to the customers
is this even what they want did they
tell you that that's what they want
are they are they giving you feedback or
are you building something that nobody
wants
and that's how most entrepreneurs fail
now you might say
well dan what about harry ford when he
invented the card ford motors
right what about back then you know he
said if i was to ask what my customers
want
then everyone would say faster horses
well that's exception
if you are selling and offering some
kind of
disruption technology that's a different
story because
then you're anticipating the needs of
the marketplace and you're essentially
creating your own market
i'm not talking about that that's a very
small percentage of the entrepreneurs
for most entrepreneurs we are more
tapping into the existing needs
the existing desires that people already
have and we're tapping into that that's
how we make most of our money
so smart entrepreneurs we never stop
listening
paying attention to what our ideal
customers
want and what they need let's say this
year and you say you know what dan
i have a certain financial goal an
income goal maybe you want to make
fifty thousand dollars a hundred
thousand dollars a year two hundred
thousand dollars a year
half a million dollars a year or you
know what you say this is a year
i'm going to make a million dollars a
year whatever your goal is
let's take simple math a hundred
thousand dollars
a year let's say let's make it even
simple 120 kids take 10k a month
10 000 a month that's your goal
so don't use the new year resolutions
concept
here's the concept i talked about in my
book fu money you can go get the book
from amazon but i'm going to teach this
to you
right now and that's the concept of d i
g d i g it stands for
daily income goal daily income goal
so let's say you take ten thousand a
month and you break it down you divide
it by
30 days each day you got to make about
340 somewhat dollars let's just round up
350 bucks that's your dig
daily income goal 350
that you need to make every single day
if you want to hit
10 000 a month now i want you to think
about this
when you get up in the morning the first
thing that comes to your mind
the first question you have to ask
yourself is
what am i doing today that would make me
350 today
what do i need to do what do i need to
focus on
what what are my objectives am i hitting
my daily
income goal what does massive action
look like
what would dan lok do ask yourself those
questions
guess what if you're not hitting your
daily income goal you are not hitting
your weekly income goal
you're not hitting your weekly income
goal you're not hitting your monthly
income goal
if you're not hitting your monthly
income goal you're not hitting your
yearly income goal
you don't need to wait till december and
you look at a calendar and say oh you
know what i screwed up
i am way behind i'm nowhere near making
a hundred thousand dollars
what is going on i know exactly what's
going on you're not hitting your daily
income goal
you can look at your progress every
single day
what am i doing today to hit my daily
income goal
oh well i kind of i'm not doing anything
today well
then don't blame and don't when you're
hitting you go
oh well you know what today i'm i'm
excited i'm fired up i've hit my income
goal you know what not just that i
exceeded my daily income goal
instead of 350 bucks a day i hit 500
bucks a day
good for you good job that means you
have that 150 bucks
buffer extra that's good doesn't mean
tomorrow you're like all slack off and
slow down
it means okay i've exceeded that today
because there are some days maybe you
hit it there's some days you don't you
got to average it out
tomorrow you get back into it wake up in
the morning what am i doing today
what am i going to do today to hit that
350 bucks
and what do i need to do every single
day to accomplish
my daily income goal the concept of d
i g isn't it much more powerful than
some new year resolutions
whatever your mind can conceive you can
achieve
but sometimes what if you don't have
that belief yet
what if you're just getting started what
if you haven't built up that confidence
i remember years ago when i was just
getting started and i was already
running my own
one-man advertising agency and one time
i was having lunch with my mentor alan
and after lunch i was driving back to
his place
and in the car i was asking him a
question
now at the time my english name was
actually daniel
daniel so it's daniel locke so i was
asking him alan i'm thinking of
changing my name and he said well what
do you want to change it
to and i said you know my name right now
is like daniel and
it's okay but it feels a little i don't
know i feel it's a little young
i want a name that has just a little bit
more punch and maybe sounds a bit more
mature
okay so what are you thinking i said i'm
thinking of showing the name to just
dan and he paused said okay
so dan like dan lok i said that's right
dan lok i think it's kind of punchy's
got that oomph to it and it was sitting
in the passenger seat
and he did this motion he said dan
lok he said i could
i could see that i said what could you
see
he said i could see see dan lok
live big banner in a big conference
i said what i said that's right that
would look good it's got
it's got impact it's impactful and i'm
like
i don't see that i'm just simply kind of
change my name to be a little bit more
memorable
how could you see sex see dan lok live
this is way before i was even doing any
kind of public speaking
i was just very much like an introvert
and writing copy right
you're hiding behind my computer see dan
lok live a big conference what do you
mean
see he saw something in me that i
didn't see he believed in me my mentor
believed in me
more than i believed in myself i didn't
see the possibility i couldn't believe
it
i couldn't even see that but he saw it
so sometimes in life
maybe you don't have that belief in
yourself that's okay
i didn't have that belief in myself but
don't underestimate
when you have someone believe in you
more than you believe in yourself i tell
my students all the time
i said i believe in you more than you
believe in yourself
and if you don't believe in yourself yet
that's okay borrow my certainty
so you can go on and develop your own
belief
and someday maybe maybe
you can use that belief to achieve what
you want
having a mentor a mentor
standing on the shoulders of giants
learning from someone who's been there
and done that it's extremely critical
why we invent the wheels why not borrow
someone else's wagons instead
right whatever that you want to do
someone else has already done it you
don't have to start at the very bottom
you can start at where your mentor is
gone
and start right at that level and then
go from there isn't that a much smarter
way to learn
instead of going through the school of
hot dogs you don't have to get it right
you just to have to get it going
you don't have to get it right you just
have to get it going
[Applause]
most entrepreneurs here's what they do
they mentally masturbate too much
i don't know let me think about it oh
i'll get back to you let me talk
no perfection is the enemy of progress
so you know what you wrote an article
you don't like who cares upload it
you you have to create a video that you
don't like who cares upload it
you you wrote a blog post that you don't
like who cares
tweet the crap out of it
there's a great quote that i love from
reid hoffman the founder of linkedin he
said if you're not embarrassed by the
first
version of a product you've launched too
late
if not embarrassed by the first person
version of your product you've launched
too late
don't follow your passion
you heard me right i said do not don't
follow your passion i say that one more
time
don't follow your passion now what am i
talking about
[Music]
you hear this all the time people talk
about you gotta find your passion
do what you love it's a very north
american thing
let me talk to you about the asian
culture we don't talk about growing up
the concept we don't talk about oh you
gotta find your passion you gotta you
gotta find what you love
no in the asian culture first you focus
on making a
living you do not have the right
to talk about passion before you make a
living
now it's a very different philosophy i'm
not saying one is good or one is bad
or they're just different if you think
about it
if you cannot pay your bills if you're
not providing for your family
you're not being a husband and not being
the wife that are supporting your kids
they can they're sending them through
schools they're supporting your parents
then you have not earned the right to
follow your passion
when i was getting started let me tell
you this
the first few years of my career i was
working my ass off
i was in front of my computer 12 14
hours a day
i was calling i was working hard there
was no
passion there's not one bit of that that
i like
you think i want to be in front of my
computer studying
learning growing doing stuff getting
called getting rejected
meeting with people doing all the hard
work i don't like one minute of that but
that's what it takes
it's not about following your passion
following your passion
does not mean you're gonna have a
successful life
because chances are when you follow your
passion
you do what is comfortable for you oh
this is what i like to do
i'll do that it's it's easy for me to do
that's not how you think success now if
you don't want success
then you don't have to watch this video
you can watch you can watch some other
videos go watch some prank videos or
something like that you don't have to
watch my video
i'm talking if you want success if you
truly want success
you have to do not just do what you love
you got to do what it takes you got to
sacrifice
once i made enough money once i'm
successful
then i can delegate the stuff that i
don't like to do i can delegate stuff
that
i'm not very good at now i can focus on
my
zone of genius now i have earned the
right
to follow more of my passion what do i
like to do
such as teaching i could do that but in
the beginning
for you young guys out there you haven't
earned the right to follow
you need to pay the bills you need to
make a living
do that first i remember when i was
just getting started my first identity
was i was basically a wannabe
entrepreneur
not a real entrepreneur i want to be an
entrepreneur i thought i was an
entrepreneur
i was trying different things and i was
starting all these businesses
none of them worked i was losing a lot
of money
then i reinvent myself to be a
copywriter right i developed that
skill they have that high income skill
as the as a young guy 27 years old
and then i developed my next skill which
is being a consultant for all the
clients i was
writing sales copy for and i was making
very good money as a young guy 20
somewhat years old i was bringing in
you know two three hundred thousand
dollars a year that's that's very very
good money
and most people would stay at that
pace stay in that same spot for a long
time but i didn't
i knew that in order to go to the next
level i had to
reinvent myself and what does it mean to
even reinvent yourself
i'll tell you exactly what it means it
means that you have to let go
of what what has gotten you up to this
point
and let go and go to that next level
that is a difficult part
it's one thing to let go of things that
didn't work for you
but it's a whole other thing to let go
of things that
worked for you so what got you here
won't get you
there so i was making good money i had
all these clients and one day i made the
decision
i didn't want to do that anymore i had
to transition from
being just a copywriter or a
marketing consultant to being an
internet entrepreneur
i needed to make a shift in my identity
and i call
all my clients one day and i fire all my
clients overnight without knowing
what the next step is going to look like
but i knew
deep down that i knew that's the right
thing to do how many of you ever had an
opportunity
that you it requires you to take some
form of action
to take that leap of faith but deep down
you know that
it's scary as but it's the right thing
to do and i did that
i followed my clients and i started and
pursue
my full-time career as an internet
entrepreneur
the one key the one key that unlocks
wealth in business is distribution
distribution is what unlocks wealth
in business in fact ask yourself this
question if you're in business yourself
right now you are selling a product
you're selling a service you're selling
online
offline it doesn't matter think about
your bottleneck
what is stopping you from going to the
next level
my guess is chances are it's
distribution
it means that you're not getting enough
exposure and attention in the
marketplace
right now and attention the right type
of attention
is the new currency if you're not
getting attention
you're not attracting customers and
buyers to your business
now think about even for a franchise
let's say a franchise network like
mcdonald
or it could be even like a starbucks
what is it
they have many many many many locations
but really
it is a distribution network it is a
distribution channel for them to sell
more coffee or more products or more
fries or more burgers
in all these different locations that's
what that is
distribution unlocks wealth in
business whenever someone is on youtube
making a video when i'm giving you
advice
i am talking to you but i'm also talking
to millions of people
because of that that advice cannot be so
custom
tailored when i'm talking to a
millennial who
is still in school trying to figure life
out or versus i'm talking to a
ceo a fortune 500 company the advice i
would give them is very very different
so one size doesn't fit for all
so you have to learn when you're
watching anyone including me
you're learning from anybody you need to
learn to filter
does it make sense for me how do i take
direct action
how does this apply to me don't take
anybody
anybody's advice as so literally you
need to learn to think for yourself
to think independently and hey you know
what does that make sense
how would that work in my situation you
see the biggest problem is
there is no excuse there is no excuse
to be dumb for you to be dumb with so
much information out there that you
could find out things
you go to google you know back then when
i had to learn something when i had no
money i had to go to the library
i had a library card i would go to the
library and i would borrow a whole bunch
of books
and every single week i would go back to
the same library and it would borrow
different books
that's how i learned because i was
hungry for information i was hungry
for experience i was hungry for
knowledge
and now with you you can just go on
youtube you can go to google
you can just type and you have access to
so
much powerful knowledge and information
there's no excuse to be dumb there's no
excuse
not to know something you don't have to
like it but you cannot not know it
being like being dumb is just bad being
dumb and broke
that's like really bad
i still remember when i was struggling
financially and i was jumping from
one thing to another going from one idea
to another going from one business to
another
looking for that perfect business
looking for that perfect
opportunity looking for everything
external except looking
within what am i missing and that's how
i had all those
business failures and i had 13 business
failures
before i found my first success
and the problem was because i was
chasing
all these things and i was doing a
little bit of this and doing a little
bit of that and
i was dabbling you notice when you
dabble you never achieve mastery and you
never achieve
greatness you look at in any industry in
any
endeavor it could be entertainment it
could be sports
even think back michael jordan when he
was
the greatest basketball players of
all time and then when he went into
baseball remember that
comment below what happened right didn't
do so well
went back to basketball and kicked ass
right
championships so if you think about
people who try to do a lot of different
things
they don't do that well what you need to
do is you need to understand
that you only have a limited amount of
time energy and resources and especially
in the beginning you want to focus and
narrow that down
it's like a laser beam focus right it's
imagine like just like the sun remember
you have that magnetic glass right
you have channel all your energy through
one focal
point and when you can do that yes that
would create
results but the problem is when you
dabble a little bit a little bit of that
try a little bit australia a bit of that
you never develop skill sets
any good skill it takes years to develop
not weeks not days not months so you
have to ask yourself
how much time am i devoting to this one
thing
and be world class at it i believe
the easiest way to influence somebody
not to convince them
not try to test the arm but the easy way
to influence somebody to persuade
somebody
is by asking them questions by asking
them questions
so when you know that the idea is wrong
instead of telling people hey you're
wrong this is no good
no one likes to hear that they are wrong
even though they're wrong
they don't want to hear that it's much
better to ask them questions hey you
know what
[Music]
now it's okay we can go with this plan
but have you ever thought about this
what are the consequences if this
doesn't work out
wouldn't it be a good idea to have a
plan b right
and you see this maybe it's gonna work
but what's the downside of this right
and can we live with the downside when
you
throw it out there and you make it their
idea
because one thing i've learned in
persuasion is this
when you say something it means one
thing when they say something
it means everything so instead of you
saying it
make them say it make them think about
it make them
question it make them doubt their own
ideas
versus you try to doubt their ideas and
also when you are communicating when
you're asking questions
you need to ask with certainty
in this world in this uncertain world
what we do is we sell
certainty in an uncertain world that's
what we do
as closers as entrepreneurs right as
influencers
people will love you people hate you
and none of it has anything to do
with you you see haters hate for three
reasons number one
they see you as a threat they're your
competition they try to put you down
for their own personal gain or they're
what i call parasites
exactly what it sounds like they're
parasites
have people the same thing use my name
set a fake facebook account
big social media account pretending to
be me promoting whatever products and
service
whatever [ __ ] they've got it's
normal
number two they hate themselves see
haters don't hate you
they hate themselves you are a
reflection
of who they wish to be
you notice a lot of haters online
nameless faceless fake name
hiding behind the keyboard the keyboard
warriors
probably a 14 year old teenager living
with his mom
in the basement that's what they do or
they read one post they watch
one video and they think they've got you
all figured out
it's as stupid as reading one paragraph
from a book
and they thought i've got the book all
figure out i know what the book is about
that's okay not everyone deserves to
know
the real you let them criticize who they
think you are
and number three they want to be you and
that's why they hate you
every single time they see you on social
media it's a reminder
or what a failure they are what they
could have done
it's easy to find fault in what you do
instead of finding fault
in what they do is the point of what's
wrong with you
then fix what's wrong in their life
that's okay
don't worry about those who talk behind
your back
they're behind you for a reason why i'm
able to accomplish
what i've accomplished at a young age
instead of
at the age of 50 55 and 60
[Music]
and that's learning from a mentor
learning from someone who's
been there and done that and continues
to do it
imagine if you are an athlete
you want to learn how to play basketball
yes you can learn from yourself yes you
can kind of play basketball with your
friends but if you want to be a
professional guess what you need to get
a mentor you know get a coach
to show you exactly what drills do you
need to practice on a daily basis
to get better what are some of the
exercises that you have to do
and he's the coach he's watching you
he's correcting you
right he's shaking you he is molding you
he's helping you to get to that next
level
that's the power of a mentor i am where
i'm today
yes i have made a lot of mistakes
absolutely
i have learned from other people my
peers yes
but i'm where i am today because of my
mentors
most people they let the ego get in the
way
of success it's very easy you notice
people say
i know that i know that i know that well
you don't know
you do not know it how do you know when
you know something
if you don't live it you don't know it
so those three words
are very very dangerous and they destroy
your potential they destroy
your success why because the minute you
say
i know that your brain shuts down you're
not listening
anymore and you're like okay i know that
i don't i don't need to listen any
further
you're not paying attention so what you
know it
so what did you know it it's not about
knowing it
i could tell you this i am not an
original
thinker let me just tell it to the whole
world i am not
an original thinker there's nothing new
about what i do
everything i learn from napoleon hill
other successful entrepreneurs
think and grow rich proven masters from
the past
my mentors there is absolutely nothing
new
about what i say and about what i do i
am a
synthesizer i take different ideas i put
it together
the only difference between me and
everybody else
is i don't say i know that
what do i say i say i use that
i use that that's a those three words
are much more powerful
than say i know that because when i use
it
i own it and it's mine i instead of
everybody else
they're thinking the ideas they're
learning about it i know that i know
that i know that no you know what
i ask how can i use that how can i use
that how can i use that i implement
the only difference between me and
everybody else i can execute it
better than most people i use it better
than most people
that's the only difference instead of
you just watching a video you watch 50
100 videos you don't use
i can use one video i can read one book
i can take ideas and like implement
execute immediately and execute well
that's the only difference
my marginal instructor said something to
me very profound a few years ago he said
you know what
as a martial artist then what determines
how
good you are and how fast you would
progress as
a martial artist it's not just how many
hours you put into your training and and
what style that you practice
what determines how good you'll become
is your sifu
your instructor and who you learn from
now at first i didn't quite understand
and later after i studied with him i
trained with him my martial instructor
i realized wow what a profound statement
because think about in a martial art
context
imagine if you want to learn different
martial arts you want to learn karma god
you want to learn taekwondo you'll learn
karate you'll learn
boxing whatever style or mma whatever
style that you decide to choose
your instructor would dictate would
determine
how good you are your coach their skill
that gets transferred to you think about
that
it's the same in your financial life who
do you want to learn from
realize when you learn from somebody
when you listen to their advice
you become them you get their lifestyle
in the marketplace a lot of the people
when they
want to price their service here's what
most people do right
especially when they're getting started
they're going to the marketplace and
they're thinking
let's see what other people are charging
right if i'm offering
let's say a copywriting service
well let me look at what other people
charge and they say people will charge
this price and
some people charge this price you see
the range well you know
maybe i'll just charge somewhere in the
middle that's how usually
people price the service that's not a
very smart thing to do
because right there you are competing
based on price
instead of competing based on value so
what dictates your price is supply and
demand
so the first thing you need to look at
is with what you do
is it a blue ocean meaning are you are
you unique
enough in the marketplace are you
uniquely qualified
to solve this particular problem for
your prospects so
back then when i was a copywriter i
wasn't trying to be a copywriter
for everybody i was trying to be a
copywriter only for
speakers trainers and people who
put together events the reason for that
is because
back in the day when they do an event
there's always a very high payout it's a
high ticket offer right
they do an event it's it's possible that
they're selling
two thousand three thousand dollar
ticket and they could have hundreds of
people in the room
and they need my marketing piece my
direct mail letters
to put button seats to fill those
seminar room
so they know even if they pay me five
thousand dollars eight thousand dollars
ten thousand dollars
to create a campaign in their mind oh
well you know if i sell
two three seats it pays for dense fee
it's easy to justify
so you need to think about when you
price what you do
what is the value that you're providing
and how can you compare
the value you're providing with the
service that you provide so you're
thinking about just well here's what i
do
you will you will not be able to charge
a lot a much
better way to look at this is okay how
can i package what i do
so now i'm selling a result i'm selling
an outcome or
better yet i'm selling money at a
discount
i'm selling money at a discount what
does it cost the prospect
not to do business with me that's a very
good question write down
what does it cost the prospect not to do
business with me
then you can price accordingly i think
that
number one leadership quality is vision
be able to create that vision to have
clarity of what the vision is
and then be able to communicate
particularly that vision to your team
consistently on an ongoing basis
i think that's the most important thing
you notice lousy leaders
you ask them about what their vision is
is usually very fussy
right they say oh yeah we want to grow
our business or
we want to grow our revenue by how much
how when what does it look like
right and how does each team member how
do they
contribute to that vision see the team
that is high performance
every single person on a team they know
how they
play a part and being a part of
that vision so what i do all the time is
i
am selling my vision to my team
all the time every single month when we
have a big team meeting
i do that beginning a team meeting
here's the vision
saying the same thing again and again
and again sometimes i would make the
vision bigger
sometimes i would pivot the steps of
what we need to do
or are we behind or we're ahead but the
vision
is so critical so what i do as a leader
all the time i'm thinking about where
are we going
where are we going and how much clarity
do i have
for myself how much clarity do i have
for the company how much clarity do i
have for the team
so i think that's the number one
leadership quality
let me tell you something that no one
talks about and why i believe
for 99 of the people watching this video
right now that multiple sources of
income is a bad
idea it takes a tremendous effort
to build up just one source of income
it takes a lot of time and effort just
to sustain
one source of income when you try to do
so many things
put in a comment what are some of the
things they're doing right now to bring
in
multiple sources of income maybe you're
doing drop shipping
maybe you're trying to make money from
the stock market maybe you're doing day
trading maybe you're doing real estate
you do
so many things a jack of all trades a
master
of none how much money be honest
are you making from each thing so
instead of trying to make a little bit
money here a little bit money there a
little bit of money here a little bit
there
you never get good at anything now i've
got a special bonus script from dan on
how to learn
public speaking that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day
i want to know out of all of those clips
that you just watched what was the
single
greatest lesson that you need to now
apply to your life or your business
let me know put it down in the comments
below and if you're still here watching
you made it this far in a video believe
nation we don't just watch videos
we do something we take action if that's
you if you are committing right now to
taking some action after watching this
video
give me a hashtag believe down the
comments as well because i want to
celebrate
you the number one fear that most people
have is
public speaking now why do so many
people
why are they afraid of speaking to
groups
most of the time because they worry
about if they're gonna sound stupid or
how do they look or they are afraid
because they might say something wrong
all these things but you look at
great leaders almost all great leaders
they're all
great public speakers such as steve jobs
right such as tony robbins warren
buffett
one of the skills that changed my life
is public speaking when i joined
toastmasters
years ago because i wanted to improve my
english
and also reduce my accent and i was
improving myself through public speaking
i developed
confidence self-confidence through
public speaking
so ask yourself are you afraid to speak
to groups
do you know how to present your ideas to
groups
can you communicate with conviction and
certainty
can you interact with your audience
maybe you get sweaty palms
maybe you were like me in the beginning
like your face
would turn pale right your needs would
be locked that's okay
it is a learnable skill but in order to
be
rich public speaking is one of the most
valuable skills that you must master hi
this is dan lok
if you're a fan of evan's work if you
want to know exactly
how to model my success i want to invite
you
to join me for a special online training
all you have to do
is click on the link below you can join
me for absolutely no charge so
click the link below and i will see you
in class
if you want to see the ultimate les
brown motivation compilation
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there you've
experienced a lot of disappointment
maybe you've already given up and maybe
you just need a little fire a little
encouragement to get back in the game
again